okay
you
[Music]
good morning everybody um welcome to
House Education it's almost like we
never left this place yeah and
so as I mentioned to several here I just
enjoyed the drive down today because I
had Glen Campbell and Ann Murray right
with me and it was very comfortable and
relaxing um for uh all those that are
here um I want to make a reference to
our what we have for bills coming up on
the uh Wednesday of this week and in the
calendar it indicates that there is a
bill that we've already
EXA and so obviously we're not going to
be exacting that particular bill that is
1397 that's the last bill identified uh
for action on Wednesday that's already
been taken care of so that will not be
discussed we've already done
it all right so what I'd like to do now
is get into the bills for today we have
the first bill on the dock it is HB 1312
requiring parental notification of
student health or well being and certain
curricular by school districts welcome
representative thank you thank you Mr
chairman and honorable members of the
education committee for the record my
name is representative Christine Perez
I'm from London da I represent
Rockingham District 16 I'm here to speak
on behalf of Bill
1312 it's uh kind of a two-part Bill an
act requiring parental
notification this bill will expand the
notification that prohibits policies
that would stop the notification about
students well-being I want to direct you
to the technical advisory that I had
passed out to all of you um This was um
issued by the Department of Education on
May 12th
2023 this advisory provided gance to
Educators when discussing issues related
to human sexuality outside the contents
of health and sex
education it reminds Educators that
parental notification is law when
discussing human sexuality in any course
context for examples English language
arts or other areas of study uh this
bill would add the word any in front of
clarify it will also expand the
definition of course material to include
sexual orientation gender gender
identity or gender expression and that
not less than two weeks notice will be
required now in doing some resch for
this right in my own town of London da I
found that their
notification um policy was from
2012 um as far as I'm concerned it might
might as well have been
1812 it had not been updated ated after
the law it became law in
2017 that parental two weeks notice of
Parental notification had been
required um it does not prevent an
educator for answering any questions in
the classroom or sharing incidental um
information for example if I was a
teacher and someone asked me um if I was
married I certainly could say I was
married if they asked me if I was was
married to a male or female I could
certainly answer that it does not exempt
that type of thing it does exempt actual
teaching outside of health and sex
education there's another part of
this that would also and I feel it's a
protection actually for for um teachers
um it would require that the schools may
not adopt policies that would stop
Personnel okay may not adopt a policy
that would stop Personnel from notifying
a parent about a child's mental
emotional physical health or well-being
sexuality or changes in services so if I
am a health an an educator and I feel it
is very important to notify a parent
about an issue that that is going on
with their child in any of these areas
this the district cannot adopt a policy
stopping me from doing that it also
allows them to have
policies that information could be
withheld if a reasonably prudent and I
did look that up and research that
believe that the child could be harmed
by that information being given out so I
looked up reasonably prudent and
basically it's a person seeking in good
faith to perform a contractual
obligation so if someone in good faith
felt that if I said something to a
parent in that child's specific instance
there could be a possibility for
harm the policy would there would be a
policy that would say that I could
withhold that
information so I believe that in view if
you read carefully the technical
advisory that came out basically it is
enforcing this bill it's saying that you
cannot teach things in art or in English
or in other subjects and if you do it
needs a parental notification of two
weeks so and I'm willing to take
questions I hope I can answer them thank
you very much representative Perez are
yes represent whitcock thank you
chairman good morning representative
good morning just want to be clear on
the clarification made so if I am te
teaching a literature course or world
literature course right and I want to
reflect back on the uh some of the art
and some of the uh parts of the story or
shakan story something of that nature I
would and it has some sexual overtones
or Inu windows or direct fact in it in
the in the literature I would have to
receive two week notice from the parents
is that correct I knew that was going to
come up
good and my answer to that
is many years ago in middle school I
used to teach to go in and talk to the
young girls um in Middle School of
course this is many years ago about what
was normal and what was not normal it's
a tough time to be in the middle school
and that it is all right and it is all
right and one of the things that I
brought out was things that had happened
in the past for example if you did not
have if you were not volumptuous way
back you were considered poor because
you couldn't afford food to be sure oh
wa this is not going to stop that type
of thing I mean if you are talking
about human
sexuality as we know it
and not trying
to push a subject this won't cover this
this is human sexuality gender gender
identification specifically specifically
as we know
it in
2024 I believe I I believe thank you Mr
chair I I just want I didn't really get
the not the answer I wanted particular I
didn't get the answer with my question
which was a on health sexual education
instruction I'm talking about I'm
talking literature or something history
uh particular back or Shakespeare um
with and it's going to involve dialogue
from the script in Shakespeare or
theater so with those folks those
teachers need to receive get the two
weeks parental uh uh notification in
English I do not believe so I think that
the district could look at the syllabus
and look and see what it is the syllabus
that we have in London are right now
is is going to be updated because I'm
going to push it because it's very vague
I would think that that would be on a
could certainly be if the school
district approves the syllabus and what
is in that syllabus okay thank you thank
you Mr chair further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
like to invite gues
Banette
ACLU good morning good morning Mr
you
U thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee gbad I'm the legal director of
the ACLU of New Hampshire uh we oppose
this bill um I want to go through kind
of the two what I think are kind of very
different and distinct components um of
the bill the first being the changes to
RSA
18611 uh Ral 9C which is the uh 14-day
notification requirement it also then
provides an opportunity of course
through that notification uh period to
allow students to to opt out I think
with respect to that first section of
the bill um I think there are two
problems with it and I I think the first
is I think we're targeting in many ways
lgbtq plus students and I think the
second problem is that is Impractical
and for for many of the uh reasons that
I think were're articulated in some of
the prior questioning um uh before my
testimony so first I just want to be
very clear at least how I read the bill
and what its scope is maybe that's not
the intent but it's certainly how I read
it this bill expands the scope of that
14-day notice and opt out period not
just to sexual education but it goes
beyond that to any type of curriculum or
instruction um or program of sexual
orientation gender gender identity or
gender expression so we're taking this
statute where we're now expanding it far
beyond what think what was its intent
back in 2017 which was to address sexual
education and I would note that
notwithstanding the department of
education's recent technical advisory
they issued a technical advisory right
when this 2017 law was adopted that I
think made clear that this was a statute
limited to sexual health so this is very
very expansive and I just think we need
to be clear um about that and so in so
doing I think again I think it is
targeting and stigmatizes any
instruction concerning lgbtq plus people
and I think it sends the message to
those students that their identities are
something to be shunned feared and uh
potentially even chilled with respect to
instruction and I just think that's a
concerning message and I don't think
that's a message that we should be
sending to those students in our schools
but I think the second concern is that
is it is
Impractical um again when you take this
outside the context of sex sexual
education
and sexual instruction you are taking
this right into classrooms like history
English social studies um and of course
in those classes there's going to be
discussion about sexual orientation
there's going to be discussion about
gender you might talk about the 2015
marriage equality decision you might
talk about the 1848 Seno Falls
Convention which is addresses directly
gender um you might talk about the
Stonewall incident of
1969 all of which I think plausibly are
covered by it again may not be the
intent but I think when you read the
bill course uh materials instructions on
gender sexual orientation that falls
within its scope so I just want to
express those those
concerns lastly with respect to um uh
section two I do want to convey the the
real concerns that we have um about
potential um for outing so we believe
that a school district policy of course
should not categorically prevent a
teacher from making a determination to
disclose uh uh such information
concerning gender identity um for
example um but of course School personel
uh should never encourage students to
withhold information from parents but
problems arise when school districts are
forced to implement policies that
mandate disclosure taking away this
discretion and that is what I fear
section two of this bill would do and
our position is that students learn best
when they feel safe to be themselves
with their fellow students with other
teachers but this uh bill in our view
would drive young people away from
trusted adults with whom they may feel
more comfortable discussing sensitive
subjects especially if they are going
through the process of preparing
themselves for how to have those
discussions with their parents which is
what we do as young people right you
know as we're grappling with certain
things we talk to our friends sometimes
we talk to trusted advisers to figure
out how to even not only uh kind of
recognize what's going on within us but
to figure out how to best approach that
with our families and I think this
actually interferes with that in many
ways so with that I'll conclude Our
Testimony but for those reasons we
oppose this legislation thank you very
much are there
questions representative
H Damon not he's not even here thank you
um thank you for taking my question
thank you could you comment on how you
perceive both parts of this proposed law
level yeah I think um this this will
come up more obviously in some of the
later bills today I think there
are certainly some legal concerns on no
tier 9 to the extent that these bills
Target and discriminate against
individuals uh who are transits which
are protected under under Federal law
and protected of course to under our
state separate laws so those those are
real concerns I think what I'm trying to
do here is in addition to all of those
concerns kind of bring this back to just
the humanity of these students and what
they're going through number one and
number two just try to in my advocacy
just kind of get the committee to think
practically just about how this would
work right if you're an educator you
know how do you comply with section two
you know um if
um in response to questions that you may
get from a student or even a parent and
also with respect to section one like
just what's covered if there's going to
be any reference to gender and sexual
orientation and I just think for many
reasons not only is this unworkable but
also again we have separate concerns
just about the targeting of this of
these um community members thank you
thank you further
questions represent cordelli uh thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you for being
here thank you um I just wanted to go
back to your comments about section one
um and um what courses this uh applies
to uh because the um topic heading for
9C is uh adopt a policy allowing an
exception to specific course material
based on a parent's determination that
the material is objectionable it does
not specify there that this is related
to sex education uh specifically um and
then it it does list um down in lines 9
and 10 in the original bill um sex uh
education human sexuality and so forth
but uh I'm not
sure how um you come to the um
determination that this whole section
relates just to sex
education I to me I think that's clear
when you look at the legislative history
and tent behind the 2017 law here which
is what this is amending and I think
also reflective of that you could just
look at the department of education's
2017 technical advisory that they
promulgated to school districts after
that 2017 law was enacted and what they
said is quote it is important to note
that the legislative intent of HB 103
does not apply to literature or other
content that might have or be perceived
to have sexual content that is what the
doe said in 2017 that is I think what
the legislative intent was um back in
2017 this fundamentally changes that and
runs completely contrary to it I just
think we all need to know that that is
what would occur if this were to be
passed thank you represent of uh
Ford thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question thank you
sir I think we're all concerned about
this issue because we're all cutely
aware how sensitive the subject is in
communities I once lived in a community
that can you get to a question quickly
please I am but I have to give him the
information before I can ask him the
question I lived in a community was
evenly divided between Roman Catholics
and fundamentalists Sir they were not in
favor of discussing these subjects in
public and yet my son asked a young girl
out to date your date regular Junior
High School activity and she SP upon him
because he studied art with a man who
was
homosexual and she didn't said I don't
date and she used the disparaging term
for
homosexuals she had concluded that
because he studied with that teacher he
must
be now how does the school deal with
that kind of
response I don't know and I think it's
it's Case by case and I think one of the
things that we have concerns about when
you have policies like this right when
you essentially have categorical
mandates um is that it takes that caseby
case determination away from from from
school district so I I'm not going to
pretend like this is easy in every
instance um but that that is why we are
precisely concerned about mandates is to
provide that discretion for um for
districts I mean we we do not I mean as
I said in my opening remarks you know
don't advocate for in every instance
that this information not be disclosed
that's that's not our position but that
it is uh something that um you know uh
should be left to the discretion of
school districts in consultation with
administrators thank repres
Dr thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question thank you so I'm
trying to reconcile your last statement
about they shouldn't um make a
determination about disclosure with the
jbab policy that our school district has
adopted that says that school Personnel
should not disclose information that may
reveal a student's transgender status uh
to others including parents and other
school Personnel unless legally required
to do so or unless the student has
authorized that disclosure so I'm trying
to they seem to be at ought yeah I I'd
have to look more closely at that policy
the policy that I have more familiarity
with is is the one arising out of
Manchester which is not a mandate for
all the reasons that I articulated that
you know again our um our position is
that a school district policy shouldn't
prevent a teacher from making a
determination to disclose such
information that it is discretionary In
Case by case and and that's what I've
advocated and it's not a new position
from our
office repr
leus thank you for taking my question it
seems like what you just said is exactly
what's in this bill so I'm not sure why
you object to this bill because it's
laying out that the teacher can use her
discretion and that the school district
can't say not
to and interrup you could you explain to
me sure that's not how I read this bill
at all in fact um and I think that is
the underlying concern that I have there
is a carve out for abuse and neglect
situations I think the concern obviously
that we have there and why that uh
doesn't cover all of our concerns is
that you can easily imagine where a
school maybe would not necessarily have
an indicia of something that met the
standard of abuse in neglect but there
could be other indicia you know that
might lead a district to decide that it
may not be appropriate so I I just think
again these are local decisions local
school district um uh concerns um and I
I that's why I just don't think this is
really ripe for adjudication at uh the
state level and you should allow
districts to address this but not
through mandates that would be imposed
by school policy under this Bill thank
you representative bony thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so in reading this bill is it
your understanding that if an English
teacher was taking up a unit on poetry
that dealt with the works of say um Alan
Ginsburg um would that because of
potential um issues that might arise
with conversations about the Poetry um
is it your understanding that the uh
teacher would have to give a 14-day
notice uh if if there's reference to
gender sexual orientation gender
identity I mean I think the answer is
plausibly and and quite probably yes
under this that's my interpretation at
least yes um so could this create a lot
of confusion for teachers in terms of
trying to put together curriculums and
what poems or what um material that
they're going to present in the
classroom I mean I think that's kind of
goes to the Impractical argument that
I'm making I just if I'm a teacher I'm
looking at this I I just don't think
particularly in an English class or high
school history class I'm just not going
to know what's what how to how to deal
with it to be honest with you are there
further
questions thank you very much thank you
manzelli good morning chairman lad
members of the committee my name is Amy
manzelli and I'm here testifying this
morning on behalf of myself and my
husband Chad trell we are residents of
Pembrook and we are here today to
strongly encourage you to vote itl on
1312 um we have shared our family story
of our 14-year-old transgender daughter
Iris and so I'm going to skip over that
part of my testimony today though it is
in the written testimony that I'll um
hand
in theond our family's personal story we
wanted to share with you how that story
fits into the context of our joint
shared American history which I have
previously shared also um putting
together some of our key historical
Supreme United States Supreme Court
cases Brown V Board of Education loving
V Virginia Reed V Reed or berel V
Hodes and just like our daughter IA
the plaintiffs in these cases they
weren't
dangerous they didn't need to be
excluded from the
conversation indeed these plaintiffs
just like my daughter
Iris they only wanted to live their
lives with the freedoms Americans enjoy
under our nation's great
laws and the United States Supreme Court
found the laws in those cases prevented
them from doing so the laws in those
cases I cited were on the wrong side of
History just like this law would be if
it were
passed I want to expand on this
theme that enacting laws that Target
unamerican laws that have targeted
minorities have not withstood the test
of time because our understandings of
fre Freedom changes over
Generations think about categorizing
today every
woman or every brown or black skinned
person as
property instead of people with equal
rights as white people or as
men nowadays we would never ever enact
laws that exclude women from owning real
estate that exclude black people from
taking out mortgages that exclude
asian-americans from voting our
changed understandings of Freedom over
Generations would not allow
that and as a back stop if laws of that
type were passed they would not pass
constitutional
Muster that is the same for these laws
such as
13312 t targeting the lgbtq plus
Community as the United States Supreme
Court wrote in OB burel
vijes changed understandings are
characteristic of a Nation where New
Dimensions of Freedom become apparent to
new
generations we know from our history
that laws targeting minorities like gay
and transgender people do not pass
constitutional
muster we also know that changed
understandings are characteristic of our
nation where New Dimensions of Freedom
become
apparent please I urge you on behalf of
our family and all of the lgbtq plus
community in our great state of New
Hampshire to itl
1312 thank you thank you very much are
there questions from the committee
rep and
leus you have me confused but thank you
for taking my
question I'm reading this just as having
to give notice and then if a parent
objects to particular material you doing
a substitute but that's a parent and a
particular child in particular material
so I'm not sure how what this is doing
is what you were talking talking
about as far
as um
limiting
curriculum in general Etc and how it
goes specifically against lgbtq since it
talks about human sexuality human sexual
education Etc which I believe involves
All Humans thank you representative leus
I appreciate your question there's two
levels of answer to to that first is the
philosophical reasoning behind writing
sexual identity and gender identity into
this law which is an unfounded belief
that these topics are dangerous bad
unsafe Etc that sends a signal to the
lgbtq plus community and the rest of the
community that is unwarranted unhealthy
unsafe for that Community it's wrong the
second thing is the Notions of
impracticality that the ACLU testified
about teachers are exceedingly busy
teachers are not just teachers anymore
teachers are guidance counselors
psychologists safety managers they do
all sorts of things they are sometimes
lesson planning from day to day to day
they may not know 14 days in advance
exactly what they're going to be
teaching sometimes they need to teach in
response to current events what will
likely happen
is that teachers will avoid gender
identity and sexual orientation topics
100% because of inability to comply or
confusion and fear about what is and is
not allowed thank you represent cordelli
thank you um aren't you trying to
ascribe um motives for this legislation
to the sponsors of the bill based on
your own
Viewpoint yes I am but I think it's a
fair
ascription further discussion or
questions from the committee not seeing
thank you very much thank you uh like to
kill
my name is Iris trell I'm an eighth
penri can you move the red down toward
you that's thank
you hear me better now yes than you want
me to restart go ahead okay my name is
Iris tal I'm an eighth grader and a
trans girl from PM this is who I am and
nothing can change who I really am I
have lived in New Hampshire my whole
life and want to be able to stay here if
these bills are passed my family and I
might not be able to stay in New
Hampshire please vote no to house bills
1312 um I'm not going to repeat my
personal story because I shared that
with you last week and it's in my
written testimony I'm giving you for HB
1312 what does this mean for me I think
teachers would be busy and would
probably just skip any teaching that
involved lgbtq plus issues that would
leave me and the rest of the lgbtq plus
students student body completely left
out and isolated from our entire
education even worse than the other bill
this would mean no representation of
lgbtq plus anywhere in my education part
of my identity would be ignored thrown
away the fact in fact all of these
proposed laws targeting me and the rest
of the lgbtq plus Community have been
like torture and I wish you would stop
if you I would like it if you keep all
protecting lgbtq plus rights including
mine thank you for your time thank you
very much Iris are there questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much pardon
me that was it that was it with that I
have no more cards in this bill so we're
me
201 we can do that thank you yeah thank
you so we're closing the hearing on this
bill
excuse
ear
that
te
s
J
be
thank
you
youis
that's
with
ch
my
I
for
we're now going to go ahead with with
the next bill on today's docket for
hearing it is HB
1356 this is relative to the use of
children's names and pronouns by Public
School
Willette and for the public due to the
number of cards we're getting here the
prime sponsor has the ability to you
know talk as long they want please don't
much more than 10 minutes though and the
others are going to be all uh 3 minute
lengths so we will cut you off at the
end of 3
minutes representative welcome thank you
Mr chairman thank you committee members
I will be much less than 10
minutes
um we call this uh HB
1356 the given name act a child's name
is one of the very first parenting
choices parents make until very recently
there was no question about who gets
aside this fundamental piece of the
child's
identity but activists in school are
allowing teaches to switch a child's
name and pronouns without the parents no
knowledge or
consent the hijacking of names rights is
more widespread than you might think in
Michigan a state department of education
official encouraged Educators to use the
students's chosen name and pronounce
without notifying the parents as did
schools in Indiana Ohio Virginia
Maryland and even in lllo
Massachusetts like these parents may
have no idea that their child is
questioning his or her gender
identity this robs parents opportunity
to support their child or to address
what might be causing the child's gender
discomfort the given name act would
restore control over child's name to the
parents where it rightfully belongs this
bill will require schools to obtain
parent written consent before referring
to a student by a name other than his or
her birth name or pronouns other than
biological the ACT protects Free Speech
as is defined by the Constitution in the
Supreme Court in instan where the
parents agreed to let a child use a new
name in pronouns it protects School
Employees from being forced to use new
identifiers where doing so would violate
beliefs but it recognizes that on a
Garcetti versus cabellos a teacher has
no constitutional right to use a child's
chosen name and pronounce against the
parents wishes in that case the Supreme
Court ruled the speech used in official
capacity as a government employee is not
Amendment social transition is a step
not to be taken lightly and certainly
not to be taken without parental consent
Dr Hillary Cass the former president of
the Royal College of Pediatrics and
Child Health Care said it best when she
described social transition as an active
intervention
with potentially serious as with any
intervention in the life of a child
parents have a right to know about about
it and accept or refuse intervention as
they see
best the only issue with the bill may be
a current nickname the child has
attached them there's an easy solution
here ask parents uh for any approved
nicknames on the forms they fill out at
the start of the school year if Robert
wants to go by Bobby his parents would
not object but if Robert wants to go by
Rhonda the permission slip he brings
home from school could be the first
indication his parents have he is
feeling uncomfortable about his
gender thank you thank you very much are
there questions from the committee
representa
Tanner thank you um I taught and Coach
Sports and oftentimes we have nicknames
for kids like
flash um sometimes we called them by
their last name like Tanner come over
here um doesn't this bill
uh say that you can't do
that this bill says that any name other
than their birth name um you would have
to have permission from the parent to do
so so follow up on that yes so
um if if I was coaching I'd have to go
to the parent and say you know the kids
are have found a nickname for Judy inner
it's Flash and uh I I'd have to do that
rather than just be normal and react to
that like I would in normal
situations that's what you're asking me
to do as a
teacher a as a coach yes
right representative Uh Wood
Cox thank you chairman good morning
representative morning um I I have two
questions one just a clarification if I
may and then a question I'm looking on
the uh bill bill in line 18 under
employer contractor shall not you're
talking about derivative Z what does
that
mean I don't have it right in front of
me if you could uh expound a little bit
it says a contractor employer shall not
use a name or address to refer a student
that does not match the name list on the
students first certificate or
derivatives
thereof
I'm not sure uh and I apologize for that
that's okay chairman lad may just do the
second yes sure thank you and I but I do
have qu a question on line 256 and 7
part three and it talks about an
employer contractor not being not
required to address youngster um because
of their religious moral conviction and
what's really difficult for me is we've
been hearing over and over and over
again te
cannot uh use their uh their position
they cannot provide their opinions on
things they can't do this now they can't
do that and now all of a sudden we're
saying but a teacher or an employer can
make the choice I choose not to do that
because on my so if I choose not to do
that isn't that violation all the other
bills we been getting that says a
teacher you can't do that you can't show
that you don't agree with that the
Supreme Court has stated that
that um a teacher does not have to um
call a student by uh uh another name
than their birth name and it's protected
uh at the same way because of a
religious beliefs or or their their
beliefs but in the same way that the
like I had mentioned through Garcetti
and um cellos that
um teacher has no constitutional right
to use a child child's chosen name or
pronounce without the parents permission
could you just give me the citation on
that so I could check that out please I
will get that back to you thank you so
much and again I apologize represent
Cole is a prime sponsor he's he's away
fine thank you chairman lad further
questions from the committee represented
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I actually have two
so the first is clarification if I'm
understanding your
introduction
um so my youngest daughter whose first
name is Nadia did not like her name when
she was an elementary school student she
does in adulthood thank you she went by
peanut which was her given name from her
favored grandfather and informed at
school that she would be peanut you I
think please confirm if I'm correct here
are saying that the school could not
accept that they would have to get
consent from the parents for the name
that the child was going by and provided
to them nothing to do with sexuality
just
a nickname it it's trying to you're
absolutely right and that's it's a
difficult uh situation
um but somehow it's on the other end of
the spectrum it's got to be controlled I
believe um my daughter's nickname was
Doodles so I I know exactly what you're
saying I do the other half
yes what does this bill do do or does it
do anything in regards to what students
are calling each other so for example
following up on representative Tanner's
inquiry if the students on a team are
whatever does the law comment on that it
does not it's just for
staff uh and Deals Only with
staff thank you for your F questions
represent
Myer thank you for being here and and
thank you for taking my question so I
want to get this
clear I'm a
teacher and I have a student in my class
kitchen and she chooses to go by the
name of
kitch in order for me to and if I'm
following what you're saying here in
order for me as a
teacher to call Susan kitch cuz that's
the nickname she wants MH before I can
do that I have to contact the
parent before I can call her kitch is
that correct that is correct thank you
further questions representative Al bony
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um um I taught for a
while and I was in a school district and
one of the things that you have to do at
the beginning of school send home a
multitude of permission forms and then
invariably you end up having to track
those down because they don't come back
so I have a student as um both
representative Damon Damon Ander has
suggested that want to be called a
particular name um that they're
comfortable with and yet that permission
slip never gets returned so that means
that student is has to always be
referred to by the legal
name by staff yes further questions from
the committee representative Cornell
Thank you thank you for taking my
question when you say contractor or
staff does that include cafeteria
workers bus drivers everybody else that
comes into contact with the child it
does who would have
no access
to any of their records or know anything
about them except they see them in the
cafeteria line and they say to them oh H
my name is is Sally and it's not but
that's what they know them as so they
would have to get permission say you
know I have can I call your child Sally
the um the staff you're talking about
are School
Employees and they would have to follow
the same rules as every other School
employee thank you further questions
from the committee represent
Cordell thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for bringing this forward
um I think you mentioned something about
how this would
um a positive aspect of this law would
be that it would help to avoid lawsuits
and I remember he
hearing a a case in California about the
idea um you gave me a look where maybe
you didn't but there's a positive idea
of how it would
avoid uh there was a case in California
which regarded
um a teacher uh being required to call a
student by pronouns and it violated her
religious beliefs maybe that was in
regard to so that um you could avoid
lawsuits like that
somehow what what the the research I did
it basically said that the um the
Supreme Court said that
um if it was against your
religious religion or religious beliefs
uh to call someone other than their um
birth name that you didn't have to as a
employee if it was your religious
beliefs okay I just want some
clarification thank you thank you
further questions from the committee
representa
Ford than thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question recently
schools have started doing alumni uh
correspondence and they include the by
addressing to the people by their
familiar nicknames from school days and
it may well be as an adult you don't
want to be called that name you may have
hated that name all your life MH and yet
they are using from the records thinking
to be sympathetic with you I hope and
elicit money from you they're calling
you by your hated
nickname how does this address
that you know when you're over the age
of 18 if you can't stand up for yourself
shame on
you in relation to that yes that's true
these are not students in
school um any further questions
from represent Willette thank you very
much thank you one more thing Mr Mr
chair if you don't mind on a different
subject um there's a bill coming up this
afternoon in your committee well talk to
me on the side about that we're in a
hearing on this one right now um so
we're going to uh do what we did
yesterday the time limit is going to be
two minutes not three minutes due to the
cards which we have up here right now on
that so the next person will be Max
Tolen
hi my name is Max Tolland my pronouns
are they them I live in Canterbury I'm
nonbinary and I'm here to testify
against this bill if HB 1356 becomes law
I wouldn't be able to learn like other
kids do my name and my pronouns are who
I am KNX is not the name on my birth
certificate but it is my name when
someone talks about you they use your
name and your pronouns when people use
the wrong name or pronoun to talk about
me or just don't use my name or pronouns
at all that's like taking away my
identity coming out is a
journey when you come out you talk to
people you can come out publicly you can
come out to your parents to your friends
but no matter what you're going to come
out to someone again and again and again
again you feel like you've told people
who you are and what your truth is and
that you still have to tell people and
correct people and remind them you have
to do this job of convincing people that
you are real and you are valid with this
simple truth once before I came out at
school I was sitting at recess with my
friends when another came up and used
the wrong pronouns to talk about me I
sat there for the rest of my classes
think about being misgendered not about
was not about whatever was being taught
in class I didn't get enough sleep that
night I was focused on how I was known
as the wrong
person last year in math class my
teacher was handing out test results and
said to me here you go here's your test
before turning to the rest of the class
to say they did a great job they were
the only one who got this problem right
I felt seen and like I was part of the
community I felt whole and acknowledged
in a good sense when my proun was used
casually and
correctly HB 1356 is a problem even in
the most ideal circumstances where my
parents write the note identifying by
name and my gender there are still
teachers who are going to look at me
look at the note and because they don't
believe in trans rights because they
don't believe that who I am is real they
will still use the wrong name and the
wrong pronouns to talk to and about me
they will take away my
identity I think that whether that
happens will depend on the school and
who teachers are what scares me is there
is no way to see which teachers are to
be welcoming and which aren't if HB 1356
becomes the law there is no way to
ensure that students will be able to
learn in a safe environment with
teachers who accept them as they are
please vote itl HB 1356 to allow me to
learn as I am ma very good timing two
minutes is right up um any questions yes
represent Tanner yes thank you for your
excellent testimony that was great do
you feel that if you're misgendered or
um
addressed in a misgendered way it makes
you more a target for harassment and
bullying it can especially dep it really
depends on who the students are who's
listening to it but especially if the
faculty use the wrong name or pronouns
these students who would perhaps
otherwise not have would definitely feel
um much more like it would be all right
to misgender me and use the wrong name
and pronouns because if the staff are
doing it shouldn't everyone be able to
do
it further questions from the committee
representative whitcock thank you sh
good morning Max can you just tell me
how old you are 12 going on 13 ah great
job well done thank you are there
further questions from the committee not
seeing thank you very much for coming
Mor
good morning good morning thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee uh my
name is Jonas suon Morse I live in
Canterbury I am the proud parent of that
trans nonbinary child um I'm a member of
the conquered monthly meeting and New
England yearly meeting of the religious
Society of friends the
Quakers uh I'm here to oppose this bill
HB 1356 dictates that even when I the
parent affirm my child's identity
teachers and staff with religious or
moral convictions can disregard my
parental wishes and the identity of my
child that exception is immoral and
unfairly discriminates against me and my
child it also perpetuates the false
notion that religious convictions oppose
inclusion and
love following the biblical injunction
to let your yes be yes and your no be no
Quakers do not swear Oaths but when I
say that I am clear to affirm this
testimony to the committee the committee
should understand that I am stating my
religious and moral convictions trans
men are men trans women are women trans
non-binary people exist and their gender
identity is real and valid this is an
incomplete catalog of the variety of
gender varieties of gender identity in
the world the biological sex assigned at
Birth is at times useful medical
indicator but it is not a more true and
accurate marker of identity than a
person's own lived
experiences I'm not a public school
teacher or staff member but if I were HB
1356 would require me to violate those
religious and moral convictions if I had
a trans student whose parents didn't
affirm their identity in writing there's
no space in this law for my religious or
moral convictions when I parent my child
but there is space for those who want
want to use religion to disregard my
wishes as a parent and my child's
identity HB 1356 is unethical immoral
and should not be the law of this state
thank you V are there questions from the
committee thank you very much for coming
Ty curse of writing
here I'm old we had to learn it
thank you my name is my name is Ty
Thompson I live in noning hun New
Hampshire I'm a transgender non-beer
person my pronouns are they them it took
me a long time to be able to say that in
the world with confidence and conviction
and I'm so proud of young people today
who are able to step into the space of
knowing and owning themselves in public
ways we need to support that this law as
we've heard with such eloquent testimony
unjust
ideally family spaces are supportive and
allow young people to blossom into
themselves in ways that are safe
encouraging and helpful unfortunately
this is not always
true sometimes families have their own
learning curve my family had their own
learning curve they are loving and well
meaning people I needed the opportunity
to choose where and when to have those
convers ations with them at the same
time I need a community for young people
schools are Community being able to
explore aspects of self with the same
freedom and celebrate aspects of self
with the same Freedom as everybody else
in the school who may be
self-identifying with athletic
qualities uh Scholastic strengths that
um incur the same nicknames or
self-identification of choice es of
names and the ways that they are called
in the world this law really just
singles out that a trans identity is
unacceptable you are the only ones that
cannot do that young people are required
to emerge in the world with increasing
agency self-direction and responsibility
we need to affirm that by being able to
support the choices that they make in
schools and in the
communities that's all I have thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee thank you
inette
thank you Mr chairman members good
morning again good morning again thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
G viset with the ACLU of New Hampshire I
know I have very limited time so I'll
try to keep this brief I know there are
many speakers behind me who I think
frankly have more powerful stories about
um why this bill is problematic and for
those reasons for the reasons that I'm
going to go through we oppose this um
this bill um
when the names and pronouns students
wish to use are
respected uh it enhances that student's
experience and it cultivates a positive
School
environment um I think in schools let's
just remember like what schools are at
the end of the day they are places where
students ought to be able to figure out
who they are uh and I think frankly
without formalistic and rigid rules from
um you know a state government regarding
names and pronouns every student is
engaged in school every one of us
probably when we were in high school
even younger were engaging in identity
exploration we were sometimes
communicating that that identity
intimate parts and concepts of who we
are to friends maybe even a trusted
school
teacher and I think it's so critical to
understand that that's just what schools
are and respecting that
um that aspect of of one's education and
frankly I think this bill would
undermine that aspect of the school
environment under this bill Public
School Employees or contractors will be
barred from using a name or pronoun to
refer or address a student that doesn't
align with that student's birth
certificate and the result will be that
schools will no longer become that space
many students need to prepare to have
important conversations about their
identity at home and I think that's
going to hinder the ability of these
students to safely seek to be identified
by their preferred names and
pronouns that is I think just using the
right pronouns is like the bare minimum
of human decency right that I think we
could provide for these students so
stripping that away I can't articulate
enough the harm that that creates to uh
you know a group of students where like
let's be real it's already pretty hard
right your your time is up the last the
last point I will make I'm going to
there's a whole host of legal concerns
please read my testimony but I do want
to just get at the impracticality the
derivatives language I don't know what
that means um also this bill covers just
Communications as well it's very
expansive and also includes contractors
which I think is also problematic for
all the reasons that were conveyed in in
testimony so I think for all of those
reasons uh we would ask that this
committee um itl this Bill thank you
very much are there questions from the
Comm
committee thank you very much thank you
Mr
house good morning members of the
committee I will be reading testimony on
behalf of Michelle s Foy who couldn't be
here today thank you chair lad and
members of the committee my name is
Michelle syoy and I am a mother of six
and a physical therapist from Temple I
writing an opposition to this bill
having given birth to four of my
children and being blessed with the
other two coming into my life through
marriage I've always been a strong
advocate for all of my children from the
moment they entered my world I have
never felt that they belong to me they
are not my possessions I have always
called them my little people as I as
they are just that their own person I
believe that they have the same rights
as we adults have and Par as parents we
are here to see that they are allowed
those rights I did not become a parent
to control their path and future I am
here as their mother only to love them
unconditionally and care for them with
no bounds my now 17-year-old has been
experiencing gender dysphoria along with
severe depression over the past few
years it has been several years that
they have been experiencing the feeling
of being lost in their own body but I
did not hear of this until their 16th
year last year my te was in such a dark
place that they tried to take their own
life while feeling incredibly isolated
and alone in their thoughts today they
have the full support of their parents
their family and their friends as they
begin their own journey to living in a
body that feels more like their home in
October they asked all of us to begin to
use they them pronouns and continue to
support them in this journey I cannot
help but think how they would have felt
if they had reached out to someone
sooner up until last January they
attended public school if my team had
chosen to speak to to one of their
teachers and ask them to use they them
pronouns before they were ready to ask
me to use new pronouns I can say with
confidence that I would have been
incredibly thankful for the support of
their teachers being able to share who
you are with the world is incredibly
important to all human beings feeling
accepted and uplifted by others when
sharing who we are is one of the
healthiest experiences we can have as
people having the support accessible in
any and every way is essential to
allowing all people to thrive in their
own lives as a parent I do not feel
threatened or G by others supporting my
child I am grateful every day that each
of them feel the love that others may
have for them and I wish this for all
the little people in the granite state
sharing with their teachers and their
school Community what pronouns they wish
to use in school will only allow them to
feel this love and Will Do no harm you
have gone beyond the two minutes thank
you thank you very much are there
questions from the committee thank you
very
me
um Michelle who who I read this it will
s read for Michelle yes thank you very
Hawkins good morning chairman lad
members of committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify today for the
record my name is Sam Hawkins I'm the
public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide on behalf of Nami Hampshire I'm
here today to speak in opposition to
House Bill
1356 Nami New Hampshire believes that
acceptance and support within one's
Community is a key factor of mental
wellness and should be a goal across all
aspects of everyday life for Youth and
Young adults and as such I would ask
that you give a lot of weight to the
lived experience of the folks who shared
before me and the folks who will share
after me and the importance of
maintaining affirming environments for
transgender youth cannot be overstated
according to the Trevor Project in 2023
roughly half of transgender and
non-binary young people found their
school to be gender affirming and those
who did reported lower rates of
attempting suicide for transgender
non-binary youth specifically respect
for their chosen name in pronouns is a
critical aspect of the support according
to a study in the Journal of adolescent
Health compared with youth who could not
use their chosen name young people who
could use their name across all areas of
their life experienced 71% fewer
symptoms of spear depression a 34%
decrease in reported thoughts of suicide
and a 65% decrease in suicidal attempts
HB 1356 jeopardizes schools and
affirming environment for transgender
and non-b binary youth putting their
mental health and safety at risk for
these reasons we urge the committee to
vote itl for HB 1356 thank you very much
are there questions from the
committee not see any thank you thank
Smith
good morning good morning my name is
Sarah Smith uh although I was known as
Sally for 21 years without any question
from anyone I'm a retired public school
teacher a good portion of our training
was in developing respect for children's
differences I spent many years among
other activities supervising children on
the playground if a child on the
playground reported that another child
had misgendered them I would consider
that bullying of the most serious sort
if an adult in the school employe had
done that I would have considered an
abuse of treatment and reported them for
it for a person in power and all adults
in school fall into this category to
treat a vulnerable child in that manner
is no different from using a racially
derogative term no matter your religious
beliefs no one would consider that
acceptable that is hate speech
misgendering a child is also hate
speech if someone did that to my child I
would file a civil rights complaint a
teacher is not supposed to be using
haast speech including using incorrect
pronouns or anything derogative to to a
protected class of students remember the
clerk in Kentucky who refused a marriage
license to a gay couple in Kentucky
in March 2022 the federal district court
judge Bunning ruled that Davis had
violated the rights of two couples and
that her religious beliefs did not
justify her refusal to issue marriage
licenses to same-sex couples she was
fined
$260,000 for these reasons I I oppose
this bill as inexpedient to legislate
slate in the
most in serious sense happen to take
questions that's all I to say are there
questions from the
committee not see it thank
savy good morning chairperson lad and
members of the committee thank you for
hearing my testimony today my name is
Emma savini I'm the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures new Futures is a nonprofit
nonpartisan organization that solves
problems through policy change new
Futures is here in opposition to house
1356 because young people have the best
mental health outcomes when they feel
supported in their communities and
schools Hospital 1356 is in direct
opposition to this
goal um we all envision a New Hampshire
in which children feel welcome and
supported in their communities um using
their gender uh their names and
pronounce that they that align with
their gender identity is a simple and
Safe Way of affirming our children and
making them feel safe and
welcome um Hospital 1356 would limit a
Young Person's ability to use those
pronouns and names that align with their
gender identities without parents WR
written permission even in the best
families where children are supported
and loved um many children feel safe
exploring their gender identities in
schools prior to coming to their
parents and in those worst case
scenarios the very very slim worst case
scenarios where children are in
non-supported families it's even more
important for children to be able to
explore their gender identities through
the use of names and pronouns in schools
we know that when young people are not
supported in families and face familial
rejection they are 18 8.4 times more
likely to report having attempted
suicide 5.9 times more likely to report
high levels of depression uh 3.4 times
more likely to use illegal drugs um and
other serious consequences when compared
to their um other lgbtq plus peers who
uh reported no to low levels of family
rejection but we know that when children
have at least one trusted adult outside
of their families um typically a teacher
or maybe a coach somebody um who is an
adult that they can turn to for support
we know that their um mental health is
on par with their peers and we know that
those uh that one trusted person adult
is a mitigating factor to uh childhood
trauma or an adverse childhood
experience um with that being said I
would ask this committee to itl this
bill and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much Emma are there any
questions from the
committee thank you thank you like to
fenelli
thank you chairman lad members of the
committee nice to see you again after so
long uh my name is Amy Manali and I'm
here on behalf of myself and my husband
Chad Chell we are residents of pemr New
Hampshire and we are here to urge the
committee to itl House Bill
1356 um again I'm not going to repeat
the story of our personal family history
with our 14-year-old transgender
daughter Iris having come out um when
she was 6 years old and I'm not going to
go through the Litany of um cases from
the United States Supreme Court
overturning laws that targeted
minorities um instead I want to give you
my final comments on how unamerican it
is to Target minorities and what that H
what happens at home when laws like this
are proposed in our family we sit down
together every single morning before
school school um every morning on the
weekend and almost every night to have
breakfast and supper together we talk
about our days we talk about our lives
and questions come up and I want to
share with you some of the questions
that have come
up uh why do people think iris is too
dangerous to use the girls
bathroom what do people think Iris will
do to them in the
bathroom why can't Iris play on the
girls team
anymore
what do you mean that people think iris
is not
safe why do people think iris is
dangerous to other players on sports
teams didn't a judge order that iris is
female and that iris is iris's
name um wait a minute I thought it was
not okay to talk about other people's
private
parts why do people care about other
people's private parts you mean a
teacher might have to be talking about
iris's private parts and other lgbtq
people's private
parts and lastly and most importantly I
thought I had civil rights at
school as a parent it has become nearly
impossible to feeli these questions
while also maintaining a positive
attitude and a positive morale in our
home and it will become absolutely
impossible if this and the other Litany
of of laws targeting the lgbtq community
are passed please on behalf of our
family I am begging this committee to
itl this bill and the other lgbtq laws
they are wrongfully targeting a minority
that does not deserve to be targeted
thank you so much for this committee's
attention and time on all of these bills
thank you very much Amy are there any
questions from the committee
thank you very much thank
you call up Iris
TRL
yep my name is Iris trell I'm an eighth
grader in trans girl from pbrook this is
who I am and nothing can change who I
really am I live in New Hampshire my
I've lived in New Hampshire my whole
life and I want to be able to stay here
if these bills are passed my family and
I might not be able to stay in New
Hampshire please vote no on House Bill
1356 I'm not going to repeat my personal
story because I shared that with you
last week and it's in my written
testimony I'm giving you for HB 1356
this could mean teachers could use my
dad name I would not want to go to
school anymore if that happened I would
never want to learn learned from an
educator who called me by my dead name
if any teacher did that I fear students
would start to use my dead name again
also that would be like torture for me
in fact all these prosecuted Pro words
in fact all these proposed laws
targeting me and the rest of the lgbtq
community have been like torture and I
wish you would stop I would like it if
you keep protecting lgbtq plus rights
including mine thank you for your time
thank you Iris are there questions from
the represent Damon thank you Mr chair
Irish thank you once again for being
here and helping us
appreciate who you really are could you
tell me what you would be doing if you
didn't need to be
here finding a way to help us help you
be
safe in school
probably follow up yes and would you
prefer
that to be honest kind of
yeah great answer thank you especially
if it's recess right don't have recess
in eth
grade are there any further uh questions
from the committee thank you very much
Trumble we're gonna ask the same
question of David here what would you be
doing
if from where thank you very
much
thank you Mr chairman um committee
members my name is David Trumble and
from the town of we I oppose this bill
first of all I think the most important
thing is that when we use somebody's
pronouns that they want we are showing
them respect and when a school has a
policy that follows that same guideline
the school is showing respect and when
Society has rules that Implement that
Society is showing respect and this bill
would destroy that respect for lgbtq
children it is very clear that the
policies that you make will affect the
mental health and well-being of
transgender children you've heard
statistics I won't read any more for you
but is worth noting that 25% of lgbtq
students use pronouns that are outside
the
binary that would be he she and or they
or they them only or Neo pronouns and
most children have friends who use
uh gender neutral pronouns so this bill
would affect a large number of people
not just the general concept of Rights
we have to balance rights sure parents
have fundamental rights to raise their
children but there is not a single
Supreme Court case that stands for the
proposition that parents can use the
school as a surveillance tool to find
out if their children have different
pronouns there is no Supreme Court case
that would carry the fundamental right
of parents to that extreme whose life
are we talking about here the parents
life or the child's life in the end the
child is the one who goes to school
every day who grows up and has a future
and we should be looking at the children
and their future well-being as The
Guiding interest in our state making
this decision thank you very much thank
you very much other questions from the
committee thank you very much you're
engleberg
hello my name is Mia Engelbert I live in
Manchester New Hampshire and I use
pronouns as you might have guessed from
those pronouns I am a transgender woman
and if I if my school outed me to my
parents I would have been absolutely
horrified I believe that all all my
transgender siblings deserve control
over their own personal stories their
their own bodies and anything else that
anything else about
them
so and if they're outed at the wrong
time by the wrong person the results
could be disastrous not everybody has a
supportive family not everybody has a
supportive peer group not everybody has
supportive
teachers they could be bullied harassed
um yeah I yeah I simply believe that all
my transgender siblings deserve to
be
respected they deserve to be addressed
choose and I don't think I have anything
else to add so thank you for letting me
speak thank you Maya are there questions
from the committee n thank thank you
have a good afternoon you too our
bestcare thanks I'm Beth scare I'm a
grandmother from nashwa and I'm here in
support of HB
1356 um this is a bill about parents
rights parents of trans identified kids
are suffering greatly I communicate with
them
frequently their kids have come under
the influence of teachers peers and
social media
influencers and parents know what is
best for their kids and they know when a
transgender identity is not right for
their kids no one knows their kids
better than
parents School staff are not going to be
there to pick up the pieces when their
child realizes
in their early 20s that the medical
interventions they followed cross- seex
hormones and having healthy body parts
removed was all a terrible
mistake and we are hearing more and more
from these young from more and more
young people that are coming to grips
with this please protect parents and
kids and vote ought to pass on HB
1356 thank you are there questions from
the
committee thank you very
much uh
uh is that an end right
there
okay apologize I had a hard time reading
name would you believe I used to teach
kindergarten and and had to write on the
board all you need to learn is learn in
kindergarten
actually I have taught kindergarten
first grade and 7 through 12 mostly High
School um and from where I got many
awards for my teaching including New
Hampshire teacher of the year I prided
myself on paying attention to my
students and um helping them when they
needed not grooming them just listening
to them so I have a story when I was at
a theater Festival after I retire ired I
was one of the adjudicators and I was
handing out the
prizes we had a person from another
school whose parents had vehemently
insisted that in the program their dead
name which is what a transperson calls
the name they no longer use be put in
the program this
child received the highest award for
acting and it was my privilege to give
it to
them and when I called them up I called
them by their true name not their dead
name and when they thanked me they threw
their arms around me and said thank you
so much and I said you deserve it you
were the best actor here and they said
no you used my
name what would you have
done thank you very much thank you very
much other questions from the
committee thank you very much we
represented
Tanner thank you very much and
congratulations on being teacher of the
year it's a tough tough thing to make so
we have one that usually is on our
committee as well I know
I'm so um my question is uh what do you
think it it does to a student in
school um to be misgender what do you
what do you see as some of the side
effects that happen I I just I can't
imagine um I have transgender friends
I've met transgender children the kids
that I know that grew up that are
transgender were not out in school um I
stopped teaching in public school a few
years ago so but I cannot imagine
because I've seen bullying I was very
often okay I was the theater teacher um
so I was very often I also taught
algebra um I was very often the teacher
that kids would come to to say Mrs
Brennan I'm gay and I'm trying to figure
out how to tell my parents and I would
listen I didn't feel like I groomed or
anything like that um but I do know what
bullying does and I remember one kid um
I don't know if he was gay but he was
being bullied by another kid they were
using the
FW and um I spoke to that kid he was
very belligerent um he wasn't one of my
students I called his mother and his
mother came in and she said in our house
in our
church there are no gays my son is free
to use that word against those kids in
the school of course then we had to get
other people involved and say yeah do it
at home you can't do it here but um I
just know how hurt kids are when they're
bullied and to
me this is the ultimate in
bullying thank you further questions
from the committee thank you very much
for coming
today and with that we're going to close
this hearing and for the committee we're
going to take a short break for people
that get up and stretch a little bit and
we'll come back and start this one up at
119 tomorrow
right yeah
understand
yes and what's the judge say put your
butt back in the
[Laughter]
chair thank you thank you very much
thank
you
yeah
think
okay we're gonna call this uh
please
I see we have uh State reps Ford and
press who's going to introduce the
Bell
welcome you couldn't pass it off to your
fellow rep there
huh thank you Mr chairman I'm the prime
sponsor and I'll be filling out a pink
card oh okay okay I my AP my apologies
it
well thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee for considering my
testimony with the intent to repeal the
law known as the right to freedom from
discrimination in public workplaces and
in education so thank you so much for
taking my testimony I am state
representative Peter patrino from
Hillsboro 43 the town of Milford so this
is a law that frankly should not be on
the books
I do believe that it is an insult to
public school teachers and it impunes
their
professionalism now I was a high school
social studies teacher for 40 years both
in private and public schools and I
served as department head and I chaired
my District's K through2 social studies
curriculum revision and in all that time
I never ever heard of critical race
Theory are divisive Concepts so I had to
do a little digging and I was surprised
to learn that this was not a New
Hampshire issue but rather a national
effort on the part of certain political
action groups who believe that public
schools are indoctrinating children with
certain beliefs about race and gender
and other so-called divisive
Concepts as I see it the law has little
to do with real
discrimination but everything to do with
silencing teachers voices on topics that
some just don't want discussed now the
bottom line is this racism is real it is
ugly and it's Insidious and it has no
place in New Hampshire or anywhere in
America now we know that the only way to
cure a disease is to confront it racism
in all forms of hatred and
discrimination is a social disease and
the only way to stamp it out just like
any disease is to confront it headon and
you can't do that if you cannot talk
about
it now look it's true that the law does
allow for the teaching of History
slavery the Civil War the civil rights
movement and so forth it can be taught
but teaching history is more than just
knowing about the who the what the where
and the when it is also understanding
the why and the how students need to
know how to conduct unbiased research
they need to be able to synthesize and
evaluate analyze the information that
they've gathered in order to form
well-reasoned evaluations about the
world they live in and this cannot
happen without honest and open
discussions when
learning about these topics now it's one
thing to tell students that the Civil
Rights Movement happened in the
1960s it's another thing to freely
discuss why it occurred in the first
place so when students are watching a
video on the civil rights movement and
they see the police dogs attacking and
the fire hoses spraying
African-Americans who are protesting for
equal rights and a student asks why were
so many white people racist back then
does racism like this still occur today
can an honest discussion ensue or does
the teacher have to say the law doesn't
allow us to attribute motivation for
such
Behavior now this is where the
disconnect is this is why teachers are
uncertain as to what they can and cannot
say in the classroom and more so there
is fear of Retribution should they allow
such conversations to take
place let's take a look specifically at
the
law I fully agree with many of the Law's
main
principles but where it teach is really
telling students that they were Superior
to others
or that others should be discriminated
against or that they should be treated
less than equal those are three
Provisions in the law well such
discriminatory classroom instruction
really happening in schools that this
law was needed to
prohibit of course not but those
Provisions make the law sound perfectly
reasonable and anti-discriminatory
the real concern is the one provision
which prohibits
identifying an individual or a group as
inherently racist sexist or oppressive
whether consciously or unconsciously by
virtue of their various protected
classifications now within that list of
all those classifications I bring to
your attention the word
creed by virtue of one's
Creed a Creed is a set of beliefs or
aims which guide someone's actions and
the fact of the matter is that there are
beliefs in this country which are racist
oppressive to women discriminatory to
the lgbtq plus Community anti-semitic
islamophobic and more Creeds are not
just formal statements of beliefs but
they're also manifested by words and
actions such as by those of the numerous
hate groups
identified by the State's Attorney
General's office does this law give
cover to those hate groups or can
classro discussions identify them for
what they
are well not everyone who agrees with
this law is racist it is safe to say
that every racist supports this
law some will say that the teachers are
wrong that they can still Teach as they
always have and others will say the
racists are wrong that this laar is
meant to prevent
discrimination but what as wrong as this
law it's a detriment to meaningful
education and it must be overturned so
we ask for your consideration to
recommend or to pass thank you so much
and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much representative uh
representative cordello thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question my concern as I read this um
very short law which seeks to repeal uh
what is on the books is um I won't read
every word it's sort of in the middle
there starting at line
four um nothing in title 15 shall be
construed as barring any School employee
kind of goes on from engaging in any
form of instruction this is the phrase
that concerns me a bit any form of
instruction it seems to me that the
current law provides what I think a lot
of people would identify as guard rails
because um
I I won't go into details of anecdotal
evidence but a number of stories that
I've read about children come home they
they go to their parents they're very
upset because they feel like they they
um after a class that they feel that
they're oh Mommy am I am I a racist and
I um you know oppressor um things like
this uh so if a teacher employs a form
of instruction that makes a child feel
that way um is that okay cuz you're
saying any form of instruction and I'm
concerned about that lack of guide rails
guard rails as I had mentioned
earlier there are a number of Provisions
in this law that sound perfectly
reasonable you have to ask
yourself okay were teachers really
instructing students that they are
superior to others I don't know of any
classroom teacher that has ever done
that or for that matter that they should
discriminate against and this is
actually in the law okay that you're not
supposed to go and teach that somebody
should be discriminated against or that
somebody should be treated less than
equal the only thing that's in this law
that I and many disagree with is the
provision that says that we can't
address the issue if whether or not
certain individuals and groups are
inherently racist and guess what there
are individuals in groups who who are
inherently racist we see it all the time
many of our colleagues have received
emails and letters from racists who have
called us awful names because of our
position regarding equality for all
people I don't know of any public school
teacher who has ever ever instructed
their students to be discriminatory or
racist thank you are there further
questions representative uh Damon thank
you Mr chair thank you for bringing this
spill forward and taking my question um
and I guess I should just clarify you
are not currently teaching is that right
I'm retired after 40 years and that's
what afforded me the opportunity to R
the state representative thank you for
your service so my question is if you
were teaching
today would you feel a need to teach
differently than the way that you did
before you reti absolutely and could you
give us a couple of examples please well
again who what where when the basic
facts can be taught but when you get to
the why and the how if you know Bloom's
taxonomy you go from the basic knowledge
and you have to work yourself up to a
place where you can begin to have honest
and open discussions particularly on the
high school level where I taught for
many for many many years uh it is really
about uh students being able to Grapple
with all kinds of information and to
synthesize it analyze it and then form
independent thinking there's a real big
difference between education and
indoctrination it's a fine line but good
teaching is about education not
indoctrination there's a big difference
between teaching and preaching it's a
fine line but it can only happen when
you go up to taxonomy and you actually
start to have serious critical thinking
issues and so to be honest this law
prevents that kind of discussion can we
actually talk about why racism has
occurred or how we deal with it right
now guess what folks racism is real it's
real we need to be able to talk about it
and honestly I don't think we can
because I'm always looking over my
shoulder to wonder whether or not
somebody's going to misinterpret what's
going on in the classroom so
thank you represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um you presented
some analysis a fair bit of which I tend
to agree with I think there like you I
said I think there's good Provisions in
the existing uh in the existing law I
think there's some areas that are
imperfect you really identified the
Creed portion as being a major problem
um I kind of tend to agree with that um
however my question to you then is is
why did you bring a bill to propeal the
entire law instead of narrowly tailoring
it to that Creed provision well because
I think that uh three of the four
Provisions in the law really are
unnecessary and it's an insult you know
one of the things that I've learned
since being here is if you want um a
chance for a bill to pass you have to
give it a very nice sounding title so
that um it sounds reasonable and then
you have to take your real intent and
you have to bury it within a whole bunch
of stuff that sounds very reasonable so
when you read this law it sounds pretty
reasonable you know we should not be
instructing students that they are
superior to others we should not be
instructing students that they should
discriminate against others we should
not be instructing students that that
they should treat others less than equal
really seriously do those three
Provisions need to be in this law
because teachers aren't teaching
students that but you put it in the law
and it sounds really nice it sounds
anti-discriminatory but wait a second
let's look at that other provision
that's the Crux of it that's really what
we want we don't want teachers to talk
about issues regarding race and gender
in the classroom we cannot call out
somebody who is inherently racist or
groups and you just go up to the
Attorney General's office and there's a
whole list of hate groups that we can't
identify and so when I brought up the
example of the student who asks the
teacher um are are some people racist
today oh I'm I'm sorry U I guess you'll
have to infer that on your own because
we really can't talk about that we're
not allowed to attribute motivation to
other people's behaviors we we don't
really know if they're racist they're
acting this way but we we can't talk
about it so again very very quickly most
of the provisions which sound really
good that you and I agree with aren't
even necessary to begin with because
those things aren't happen happening but
the one thing that you and I do agree
with that's going to go one followup if
I may just a follow up because I think
you clarified that the other the other
things are are issues the idea that
they're not necessary because isn't
happening but if if you're familiar with
it um can you talk to the um the
teaching of the concept of privilege
based on things such as race gender or
religion and how that concept is
actually different from teaching any
sort of superiority or inferiority
I'm not sure I do understand uh your
question please re re restate that or I
didn't hear everything you said uh well
if if you are familiar with the concept
of privilege that is taught in schools
can you explain how the concept of
privilege is not is a concept that is
not fundamentally similar to the concept
of Supremacy or
inferiority well I think with any uh
topic whether it's a privilege or
superiority uh honest open discussion a
free exchange of ideas um because one
person's a concept a definition uh maybe
different from somebody else's but again
that's the whole difference between
teaching and preaching when you when you
put something on the table and you have
an honest open discussion you can have a
free-for-all of ideas you don't want to
define something okay but you want to be
able to offer different perspectives and
then have students um take that in and
make their own opinions I mean we here
we are um all of us sitting around this
table with different points of view and
the point of view that we have comes
from a place of reading reflecting
thinking conversing with one another
rather than just be close-minded into
our own little world we try to open up
discussion and be honest with one
another and that's how you have
education the other way is to tell
people that's indoctrinating I'm going
to tell you what is right and wrong this
is what is this is what is isn't that's
indoctrination but when you have open
discussion and a free exchange of ideas
and people are free to have their own
thoughts now we're talking education as
opposed to
leus I'm going to ask
you what you think of a few things that
I and friends of mine actually
experienced I had a
friend she very blonde lady married to a
very black man six kids all different
colors
the palest one of the kids came home
from school I was there when this
happened came home from school in tears
because she was a racist because she was
white and her teacher said all white
people are racist and she was very upset
because did that mean she didn't love
her brothers and sisters or her father
just because she was paler than her
siblings she was very upset by that and
a young boy came
home very unhappy because his best
friend was a girl and he was told that
all men were
oppressors and he was in tears I don't
want to hurt my best friend she's my
best friend but she's a girl and they
said that all all boys are oppressors
and that means I'm going to hurt her so
are those things and those happened
before this law was past are those
things things that should have been
being taught and that maybe this law
might have curtailed well what I would
say is that there's something wrong with
that teacher that's not that's an
individual who should not be in the
classroom and so absolutely but I think
you can look at every single profession
whether they're police offices whether
they're Catholic priests whether they're
elected officials where you will find
individuals who violate the public trust
and in each of those instances we deal
with the individual who has perpetrated
um uh the situation and we deal with it
accordingly and so
um yeah so there are some people who
should not be in the classroom but we
don't paint everyone with the same brush
and one of the things I find most
offensive as a former educator and now
being a legislator and seeing some of
the bills that are coming forth it's
like we're painting all Educators with
the same brush we want to use that
example to go and say look at all these
teachers and look what's going on in the
schools and that's not true we have
quality police officers who should not
be malign because of the inactions of
others we have very good priests we have
excellent legislators and we should not
be judging all because of the misdeeds
of the few if I was the administrator
and that teacher was in my school I
would see to it that we'd be taking
action against that
person thank you very much we have 10
cards up here and we're running out of
time I'm already going to have to nail
down the those tesy to two minutes we'll
have to go less is this an imperative
for is it relevant to the
ahead thank you for taking my question
recently for um
all of us have discussed there was a
politician who was asked a question
about the cause of the Civil War and the
answer was not satisfactory to all
people in the community each group for a
different
reason when I heard it as someone who
grew up in
Louisiana a white
person and was taught that the Civil War
began at a point and it was a question
of states rights to do a whole whole
category of things I think of the war
starting at a different time than
someone who says it only started when
Lincoln decided to make race the issue
and then it pivoted and that became the
prevailing issue and it carried the
day but it wasn't the start of the war
and so if I raise that question am I a
racist for
saying the war started before you said
it started or before became about your
group of people or my group of people or
whatever I'm just trying to get at the
historical truth and yet the
interpretation is you're a this or
you're a that because we live in that
kind of society today as does the
teacher and the students so how does
that affect what you're trying to object
to when what I would say we're trying to
teach the truth there are a lot of
reasons for that war a lot of people
died before you think it even started
some were white and some were
black and I grew up with people and
another weapon I talked about is people
who were reared by black people like us
people like
us we knew who ruled do you have a
question yes I do well get it done
quickly please okay thank
you my question is what's the truth and
how do you teach that absolutely
so first of all history is written by
those who study historiography and
they're the ones who write the textbooks
but even then what is written is always
uh up for further discussion and
interpretation and that is why when you
teach and you're only teaching about the
who what where and when you're giving
the basic facts and maybe there is a
different perspective and that's where
you come up with the wise and the house
and you start reaching those higher
order thinking skills qual quality
education is about having honest and
open discussions where everything is on
the table whether we agree or we
disagree but yet we're able to talk
about it and when the day is done we can
all walk away with our own points of
view you know we all have opinions but I
like to say that opinions mean
absolutely nothing if it's not based on
well reasoned research come with the
information and present it and then have
sound arguments otherwise opinions are
really meaningless because it's yeah
this is how I feel really why did you do
the research did you look it up you did
let's hear it oh wow I never considered
that point of view before thank you very
much honest and open discussions this
law does not allow for honest and open
discussions because frankly there are
some things that are just a little too
sensitive for people to talk about this
is really about education not
indoctrination thank you very much
committee I appreciate it thank you very
much I'd like to invite represent pres
and we're going to go down to the
two-minute rule for those that are
Hereafter
first first
name good morning uh my name is the
state representative Maria Perez and I
represent District 43
I'm here to testify and support of this
bill um it's an imigrant from Al
Salvador let me tell
you I've
been discriminated against by saying
that I'm
AO I'm very proud that my mom was an
indigenous person my dad was from Spain
a white person when my dad met my mom
she was an indigenous person who never
wear shoes before she met my dad she was
working bare
feet I have a brother who's a famous
artist around the world but people don't
know that because people only take the
time to tell me that I need to go back
what I came from that my family doesn't
belong
here the people who look like me we only
here to cause troubles and we don't give
anything back to the community or we
taken away from people
here I just want to let you know that my
family is
byal my grandson is a white little boy I
love him today and I'm expecting another
one in
June I'm proud of have a bir racial
family I just want my my grandkids and
my grand grandkids to learn a history
the history of my
family the history of my my dad who was
an architect he was one of the
Architects for the most famous buildings
on Al Salvador but people don't know
that I want the stories of families like
mine to be teach I'm not here to erase
anyone I'm not here to say you know I'm
better than you or you better than me
I'm just here to tell you that I'm equal
as you and I just want my family and
Advocates who look like my family to
have the opportunity to listen their
you
it's I'm a real
technician thank you very much are there
any questions for represent
Perez thank you very much representative
minutes
welcome good good morning still good
morning right it's uh Deon for New
Hampshire state representative for
district 40 That's Manchester WS 1 3 10
11 and 12 um but more importantly I come
before you today as a parent and a
Community member of Manchester New
Hampshire um and I am here to support uh
this bill um
1162 um for multiple reasons but I will
keep it short because 2 minutes is a not
a long time so um part of the problem
that I have with the current law is that
it says historical um and so when I
think about what's happening now where
we have um conflicts in the Middle East
where we could talk historical pieces of
it but we should also be talking about
the current issue at hand with these
particular topics especially in the high
schools um and so what about the present
and what about the future of these
conversations the current law states
that is only a larger conversation can
happen when in regards to the historical
nature of the issue um and so I think
about conversations that we can have
currently with our
students and then secondly I want to
point out that complete history is
important hearing from the winners and
losers gives us a full picture of what
happened and so uh a member on this
committee stated that they were from a
certain area and this is what they
learned well that's what you learned at
that time we have more information we
have more voices we have more opinions
when it comes to historical pieces right
uh George Washington crossed the
Delaware River but that we just heard
that from the outside perspective what
did George Washington think what did the
guys who were roaring the boat right we
need all of those P perspectives to
fully understand the important American
history that we have in this country and
so if this law is repealed and Bill 1162
is passed we will be able to get the
complete and colorful history of America
without hiding behind well this is what
I learned and I think it's important or
uh we're going to stop the conversation
right here let's keep having the
conversations um and I will leave with
this final note we just had um M day um
and I spoke in front of some students
about the Beloved Community um and the
Beloved Community is not the avoidance
of conflict but is the meeting of
conflict and having conversations and so
if we want to build a Beloved Community
um here in New Hampshire we should pass
HB 1162 and repeal the current law thank
you thank you very much representative
Ford are you willing to take questions
yes representative Pell thank you very
much and thank you for taking my
question
um this bill would repeal RSA 193 colon
40 and I'm curious if you act um are
familiar with 193 col 40 Roman numeral 2
which states nothing in this section
shall be construed to prohibit
discussing as part of a larger course of
academic instruction the historical
existence of ideas and subjects
identified in this section do you think
that that section of the law prohibits
having conversations about any of the
topics in in the earlier section of this
law I did the reverse thing uh I think
uh that section is actually the part
that got me the most because academic
instruction we hear I I work with high
schoolers and there are a lot of
conversations that are about academics
but are not academic instruction um and
so how do you have a conversation with a
student will not violate this particular
piece of the law um is really diff IAL
and so let's say we're talking about
race and slavery or let's talk about
reconstruction and black businesses um
and a student is talking about how their
parent is trying to get a a a bank loan
and they think it may be related to race
right do you say let I don't want to
talk about your family trying to open up
a business student because it's about
your black parent trying to uh get a
loan or um and it has no academic
instruction and is not historically tied
to uh the Tulsa Race riots which were
also known as the Black Wall Street
which is financial hub for black people
in Oklahoma at the time right so you can
make these academic connections but if
you stop the conversation of where
students are right they only have their
perspective so race to them is what they
learn from their family from their
community and from their their their
their their local community and so when
they bring that into the classroom you
cannot say your lived experiences must
stop at the door because we're having
academic instructions in this room and
so when you do that you prevent students
from actually bringing their full s to
the classroom and so because there's no
student that I work with who lives in
the history there's no student I work
with that lived in the 1960s so when we
talk about historical that has already
been written and there are other stories
and voices that need to be heard and you
cannot relate that to um real lived
experience that students are having
today in an academic instruction way
that this bill the current law states it
thank you very
followup so do you think that that if
section if Roman numeral 2 was Rewritten
to incorporate some of the your concerns
would that affect the way the current
law is
written to make it more
palatable to be honest I dislike this
law in general and I will state
personally the intent behind this bill
is um it's not great what has been
written here parts of it and has been
mentioned multiple times from the the
primary sponsor and others on this
committee there are great pieces here
yes we love that part but what was the
intent behind the law so let's get rid
of the law completely because we can
continue to have these conversations and
this this the current HB 1162 gets to
let's not discriminate let's keep the
parts that really work well um and I
think if the only the only thing is is
once again we're creating legislation
that hinders the ability to have
conversations and have these topics
discussed in an academic class room um
and so let's repal the entire uh RSA um
for that for that matter thank you very
much are there further questions from
the committee thank you very much thank
Robinson hello everyone thank you Mr
chair thank you committee for the
opportunity to speak my name is Sarah
Robinson I'm the education Justice is
campaign director for Granite State
progress and I am here in support of HB
1162 by now we are all aware of the
effect the band Concepts law has had on
our Public School classrooms and I want
to speak today uh what I want to speak
about today is the effect this is having
on my own children and their future as
members of a local and ultimately Global
Community my daughters attend a public
school that my family is very proud of
my husband and I have strong
relationships with our daughters
teachers our girls are excited to go to
school and are valued in their classroom
the Dark Cloud that the band con concept
bill or law pardon me has cast over our
Public School classrooms will not Escape
our experience despite our strong
involvement with our children's
education when I was going to school I
was taught that states rights uh were
the cause of the Civil War while the
role of slavery was minimized instead of
being taught to fully examine the
pivotal role racism played its lasting
Legacy and how to build a better future
I want better for my children so that
they are able to treat their peers of
all Races genders and backgrounds with
dignity and respect a small group of
anti-public school politicians want to
fear Monger instead of examine what
looks what it looks like to talk about
the past in an honest way we can all
come together to overturn this law and
start working toward a better future for
New Hampshire's public school kids I
want my children and their peers to be
prepared for interacting with a wide
range of individuals as they continue to
grow on their individual paths and to
have an honest shared understanding of
the world around them and I don't want
laws like band Concepts to make teachers
fear for their livelihoods when they
teach our country's hist history or
explore difficult concepts related to
race gender ableism and more there is a
clear and consistent attempt by certain
decisionmakers to minimize an honest
education to seow doubt in our public
schools and defund those institutions of
public good to make it harder for
certain students to see a healthy
thriving future for themselves and
ultimately to dismantle public education
the band Concepts law is a part of this
effort now that the anti- critical race
Theory hysteria has died down as part of
the culture wars and ultimately has
evolved into the
anti-lgbtq and anti-al uh rhetoric we
are now seeing it's clear that the band
Concepts law was one part of a larger
plan your your time is up thank you very
much Mr chair I'm happy to take
questions you have written testimony I
will submit them electronically are
there any questions from the committee
yes representative Tanner thank you yeah
um and thank you for taking my question
do you ever think that your daughter
comes home from public school and maybe
says to you something like
you know I I was called a racist today
or your son said you know I was called a
sexist so that means I'm going to hurt
my girlfriend that maybe that was a
misunderstanding with what was going on
in school did have you ever had any uh
situation where your children have
misunderstood and maybe you needed to
clarify some things uh my kiddos do
attend a very diverse school which is
something we're really proud of and I
like to consider those teachable moments
where my kiddos and I can have an honest
conversation they can give me more
context about their feelings and the way
they're interpreting something at school
kids are going to question their
surrounding that's a normal part of
growing and my role as an adult
especially one that values diversity
equity and inclusion is to talk about
our role as people in that system and
our responsibility to dismantle white
supremacy within it um I have frequent
conversations with my kiddos about what
does it mean to be a white person what
is whiteness it's not something that
they asked for but it is something that
they live with and there's no need for
that to interrupt their ability to build
great relationships but again I'm their
parent that's my job to guide them
through uh understanding these
situations um and Educators can be
trusted to do the same
thing thank you further questions
representative uh
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question what would you
consider the band
Concepts um I think it's vague on
purpose it is difficult for the law to
be interpreted accurately by Educators
so the the vagueness being if you
approach uh topics such as race gender
uh those two in particular or even
ableism agism any of the isms it can put
Educators in danger of Retribution from
a small a minority of people who are
looking to sew distrust within the
public education system so instead of
putting their livelihood at risk
um some choose to step away from even
attempting to walk into those Waters and
have those
conversations represent
Woodcock thank you chairman L thank you
for being here almost good afternoon
yeah you seem to be like uh very well
connected with your youngsters your
youngsters so um as they come home from
school uh do you notice anything missing
uh in there in your interaction with
them in terms of information because of
the being concept act I'm very lucky
that my uh kiddos have very Savvy
long-term Educators who um feel
confident in uh the teaching that they
do in their classrooms I cannot speak
for every educator um or for the
environment that they teach in um so I
think it has a lot to do with the
community that folks are teaching within
um and their feel for the community and
if they feel supported by their
community in in teaching such things um
but again if our Educators don't feel
that they have the support of the law to
be able to teach the way that they feel
is just and honest and inclusive uh then
they will miss things thank you thank
you for the question thank you very much
representative cordelli thank you thank
you for being here yeah um I think you
mentioned something about dismantling
whiteness um aren't you stereotyping in
um place of maybe other stereotypes that
this language is trying to get rid of
I'm not sure I understand your question
could you reframe it for me sure um if
someone said they wanted to dismantle
Blackness I'm sure you would not be
supportive of that kind of discussion so
why is I'm understanding I think I'm
understanding so um the black community
has a very rich culture that is separate
from whiteness um that involves uh
ethnicity um different cultural
experience is whiteness is not a culture
whiteness is a structure that was
established to create a hierarchy within
our society I am French Canadian that's
an identity that's a culture whiteness
is not it's just a tool of a system so
yeah I would very much like to dismantle
a tool of a system that's being used to
oppress other
people than follow um and so whiteness
is that saying that white people is
that's part of the structure that you
want to get rid of um in in terms of any
um positions held by white people of
Authority or I'm not sure where are you
going with that I'm not sure where your
questioning is going with that actually
um I think there are ways that we can
identify a structure that does not serve
the entirety of our communities um I'm
not asking that folks be removed from
positions only that we examine the ways
in which we interact with each other and
use different systems to keep people
away from positions of power repr
McDonald thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for your
testimony I agree with a lot of what the
prime sponsor stated the intent of this
was to be anti-discriminatory I think
the disconnect is along the lines of the
word inherent I know he mentioned that
there were inherent groups that could be
racist do you believe that there are
racial groups that are inherently racist
and if so is that something that should
we should be teaching in schools so I
can only speak to my experience as a
white person existing in New Hampshire
and in the United States um as far as
inherency that feels like we're sort of
playing with semantics what I'm really
concerned about is removing a bill that
has put a chill on our classrooms and
has made it difficult for educators to
teach to their fullest capacity and has
limited our kiddos from being able to
learn to their fullest capacity may I
ask a followup yes do you believe that
there is any role in the department and
I it is my understanding they have tried
to correct the issue or clarify how the
laws to be interpreted do you believe
that could alleviate the chilling effect
as you put it and clarify how the law is
in at least intended to be interpreted I
think providing Clarity to a bad law
doesn't make the law any better I think
removal of the law is the ideal uh step
forward okay thank you y thank you repr
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony I just want to make
sure I have a prop understanding uh see
your testimony regarding whiteness are
you're suggesting that there was a
historical construct that we call
whiteness that was set up in order to
reproduce itself and elevate a certain
Class cast of people in America to um to
again to reproduce this culture of
whiteness is that what you're you're s
suggesting yeah and if I may have a
followup is that not the exact same
language and theory of Carl Marx's
theory of Marxism with whiteness instead
of capitalism I don't know how that's
relevant to the conversation that we're
having here or how it's relevant to the
bill itself um and I don't feel
qualified to speak to Marxism but thanks
for the attempt thank you further
questions from the committee thank thank
you very much over represent pil did you
have a question yes thank you so um I
want to go back to oh sorry thank you
and thank you for taking my question so
I just want to use your concept of
whiteness and insert it in the statute
the way it's written right now so
because there are various groups
mentioned um in this bill so if we say
no pupil in any public school in the
state shall be taught instructed
inculcated or compelled to express
belief in or support for any one or more
of the following that
one's whiteness I'm using that for to
replace color is inherently Superior to
people of another
color it sounds like what you're saying
agrees with what is written in the law
that you would not teach that your
whiteness is superior to anybody else's
color so first off whiteness is not a
correct so then I don't have concerns my
concerns are for federally protected
classes of people not being properly
represented in our education whiteness
is very well represented in education in
the United States and in New Hampshire
one
followup the law is written mentions
color which people are often yeah people
are often discriminated against because
of the color of their skin you would
right
yeah thank you very much thank you very
much for testifying today thank you Mr
Wilson thank you very much
representatives for having me
um I've shortened my speech to get right
to the most important point my name
excuse me my name is Holly Wilson I
teach us history and world history as
well as English language arts at we
Middle School in moer New Hampshire I've
been an educator and an Alpine Ski coach
life I would like to tell you that I'm
here in support of this to repeal the
divice of con Concepts law and I want
like to tell you an personal experience
the outcome of that
law has caused teachers to avoid
controversial subjects thus not helping
students learn how to form their own
opinion using facts and deductive
reasoning this law has created a sense
of fear in teachers it contributes
enough fear that teachers will avoid
those Rich discussions only give facts
and thus neglect the basic element that
all history is jelled in P perspective
and its
formation I experienced this firsthand
when I unknowingly became wrapped up in
this law two years ago I was teaching US
history and supplemented my curriculum
with the young adult version of stamped
by ibam keny and Jason Reynolds I was so
scared of this law I studied it to make
certain I was not in violation of the
law before we read this controversial
book in my classroom which by the way
was very
entertaining and the students loved it
it inspired Rich discussion and debate
in my classroom yet somebody who did not
agree with the politics of it came into
my classroom and anonymously took
pictures of the decor the posters that I
had in my classroom my lesson plans and
notes and turned me into the state in
September of 2002 claiming I was
violating the divis divisive concept law
then to top that off our commissioner of
Education used them them in an oped
supporting his idea of family values in
up thank you want any
questions represent
Miler I'd like to thank you for being
here thank you Mr chair I'd like to have
you continue to talk about the impact of
uh your teaching and what happened when
that case was filed with the state is
happened
ultimately the law was vague and the
doe the the superintendent got involved
and the doe sent all of my lesson plans
up to the doe and they looked at what I
was doing and said there's no violation
of any law although they are not a body
who
would reprimand for for Vi for breaking
law it's so vague that no one could
really pinpoint and so ultimately uh
nothing happened I was worried about
losing my teaching certificate my
principal thought she could lose her
principal certificate and of course
ultimately the superintendent's
responsible but thank
you so as a result of this experience
that you had what impact did this have
History the impact that this has had on
my teaching of history is I am very
careful with the words that I choose
with
students represent
Tanner could you tell me um or I guess
I'll ask did it change the um dynamic
between you and your students in class
or fellow Educators because this was all
done
anonymously 100% of my students I spoke
to about this and staff I worked with
were in full support of
me
nobody said oh yeah you're not a very
good teacher you probably I could see
where talking about that book you may
have made kids feel most of the
population I teach are white made them
feel racist none of that I received a
lot of support and there was support
from many conservative par parents when
I was trying to figure out who who did
this to me and I did in the end find out
who did it to me thank thank you very
much represent woodcot thank you are you
still using that that guide that book
yes thank you forther questions thank
you very much for coming
Hamlet thank you Mr chair welcome my
name is Joan Hamlet I a state
representative from Rockingham District
26 which is um Portsmouth W 3 and I am a
co-sponsor of this
bill immigration is not poisoning the
blood of our nation but racism
is how can we end the scourge of racism
that breeds fear suspicion distrust hate
and intolerance in our country
armed with true and accurate knowledge
of our history and encouraged by
teachers to discuss and examine the
accomplishments and flaws of our
policies students will gain a deeper
understanding of how history has
influenced the beliefs and opinions we
have
today we must not threaten teachers with
disciplinary sanctions or civil action
for allowing open and honest discussions
in their
classrooms in fact it is only with open
and honest
discussions that students can learn the
underlying causes of racism and can then
explore how to move us forward toward a
more tolerant and peaceful
Society I urge you to support House Bill
1162 to give teachers the tools and
confidence to provide diverse approaches
to instruction that encourage critical
thinking and an understanding of how
history affects our attitudes today
let's end the scourge of racism once and
for all by supporting our teachers and
allowing openness and honesty to
flourish in their
classrooms thank you thank you very much
representative representative
Aon thank
you could you
comment how you think the current
law
might affect a teacher today who wants
to help students look at the current
situation in the Middle East and
process the actions on both
sides thank you for the question
um yeah that would be an important issue
for teachers to discuss but I think the
law is so vague the teachers are afraid
to dig into it very
deeply thank you further questions from
the committee thank you very much thank
that thank you Mr chairman members of
the committeea on behalf of the ACLU of
New Hampshire I'm the legal director uh
there uh we are here in support of this
bill I'm going to be um very brief um I
know it's been a long morning um uh I do
want to uh be very clear and just be
transparent that I am one of the lawyers
um challenging this law it is in court
um it was a lawsuit was filed both by
aft New Hampshire and another lawsuit by
um uh two uh Educators and NAA New
Hampshire filed back in December of 2021
about four or five months after the law
was enacted that is still going through
the court process there was a motion to
dismiss filed the court rejected that
motion to dismiss there was since uh a
period of Discovery where information uh
you know was um um um information was
presented by the state to the the
plaintiffs and then there was oral
argument on on what the outcome should
be in that case um that occurred uh in
mid January so we're just on the tail
end of we're awaiting a decision so I
just wanted to make sure that the
committee just knew obviously that
there's there's some litigation on this
law uh and I'm one of the lawyers
involved in it and uh the reasons that
that lawsuit was brought are just the
same reasons that I'm going to evate to
you the concerns that we have is that
this law um is so unclear and vague that
it it fails to provide necessary
guidance to Educators about what they
can and cannot teach uh in their uh
their courses and I think the ultimate
concern that we have is kind of the
ambiguity surround rounding the concepts
but it's accompanied with real real
penalties right for educators um this
has been bootstrapped into the educator
code of conduct so you know if there's a
violation there could be a whole host of
of sanctions you know um going all the
way up to um loss of license which is
one of the the penalties under the
educator code of conduct so the dynamic
under this law right when you have uh
ambiguous terms uh combined with real
penalties for violations it just creates
a natural chill in classrooms with
respect to educators not wanting to get
anywhere close to the perceived line
whatever that line is when we're talking
about race gender any any of those
things so those are the core concerns um
that we have had throughout um and you
know I I I do just want to be very clear
I just think there is tremendous
uncertainty among Educators about what
is is covered here you know is the book
is Tiffany jueles book this is
anti-racist Ban under the ACT which is
one of the the books you know it's for
middle school kids um it's about and you
know kind of you know self-empowerment
right including for students of color is
that covered and it was one of the books
flagged by various proponents um of this
law and we can't even kind of get
answers as to what's covered so I think
that is really the underlying concern
that that we have throughout so for all
those reasons we would just ask and the
reasons in my written testimony we would
ask uh for the support of this
legislation thank you very much
representative cordelli thank you thank
you for still being here thank you
representative maybe you could point out
to us um you mentioned um vague terms
should you point out a couple of vague
terms to us absolutely um how long do
you have
um so uh you know if you want to buy
lunch let let me just start with there's
really two I mean I can okay I'll keep
it very succinct just to just some of
the core problems but there are many
right so look at Concepts band Concepts
three and four right there are questions
does this include instruction or even
teaching or even discuss ing things like
affirmative action right which is a race
conscious approach to remedying racism
well I think arguably that would be
covered under Roman numerals 3 or 4 or
maybe not depending on who you talk to
right Could you teach Justice Sodom
mayor's descent in the Reese's
affirmative action case which talks
about the importance of race conscious
remedies could that be included in a
discussion right because it's not just
the teaching that's baned under this law
it shall be taught we all know that in
in school it's not just teachers that
are instructing it's also things are
done you know can be done through kind
of the Socratic method style right all
of those things highlight the
uncertainty that exists with this law
right we all know that Educators like
law enforcement and other professionals
have to make split-second decisions in
the classroom they need to respond to
students and their questions and their
concerns and so with all of these terms
they just don't know where the the line
is even to do something as simple and
basic as to validate the concerns that a
student may be presenting right so I I I
don't mean to give a longwinded answer
um I just I think that's just one of
many concerns that that we have had and
why the litigation was brought thank you
representative Damon thank you thank you
for taking my question thank you
representative could you comment about
the existing
law and how it could
impact uh a health teacher or school
nurse perhaps talking with students
about body size and
about the fact that large
people are often discriminated
discriminated against for instance in
hiring decisions yeah and how does that
uh how is that in I think that's a great
question and it is um you know one of
the examples right is just look at kind
of disability Doctrine right one of the
concepts that we have under the Ada is
that we don't treat all individuals
equally but as a matter of equity we we
actually give certain individuals
including those with disabilities
actually different treatment in order to
create Equity we're actually uh you know
providing reasonable com accommodations
in part because of those differences by
kind of throwing disability in the
statute it kind of really it it it
creates these questions well like gosh
could you even like talk about that
basic concept um so I just want to throw
but put that example out there because I
think it's even outside the race gender
context in which we kind of normally
discuss some of the concerns we have
with this bill there are other areas as
well and I just think it it shows the
Law's amb ambiguity the kind of
clunkiness you know in in just how it's
was originally written I'm not accusing
anyone here of clunkiness I'm just as a
lawyer kind of looking at it and trying
to think about its practical effect
thank you very much Ron
Damon so if I were that health teacher
and I prior to this
law might have presented or fostered
discussion with students
around the possibility that a large
person can also be a very healthy person
depending on their life style behaviors
and how they take care of themselves
would I now be on a uncomfortable
terrain to do that well you you
certainly would be if you suggested that
you know to to um accommodate that
individual to make sure that they have
all the opportunities that everyone else
has they they should be treated a
certain way maybe in ways that's
different from someone else in order to
ensure equity in school I think that's
actually precisely where um you could be
running a foul of this lost terms and
I'm sure that you know this the
proponents of this say that's not what
we meant but you know it it I think it's
in the text of the statute and when you
combine it with penalties boy that's the
recipe for real real concerns represent
R thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question thank you
representative is the intent of the
lawsuit the same as the intent of this
bill and when are you thinking there
might be a decision uh the the um the
relief that's sought in the lawsuit is
is a a junction against the law um when
there would uh which when will that
happen I don't know I don't think we
should be discussing that here I I don't
the short answer is I don't know but I
just wanted to make sure the committee
knew thank you very much than you
further questions thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman uh Megan
officing
good afternoon good afternoon chairman
lad members of the House Education
committee I will submit written
testimony I have three paragraphs to
read because most of what I was going to
say has already been said and so I don't
want to repeat anything in interest of
time for the record I'm Megan tutle
president for NAA New Hampshire
representing about 177,000 Educators
across the state I'm also a mom of three
boys that do attend public school so
this does affect me that way as well and
an 18year veteran social studies teacher
of 8th grade and New Hampshire from the
beginning has held that the current laws
vagueness would have that chilling
effect on Educators throughout the state
we've watched this law in action for the
past 2 and a half years we know it's
true and I can't say anything else other
than what M Wilson has said and so I'm
just going to leave the testimony for
that um for how it's actually impacted
them last thing teachers are trained and
experienced in education they have a
duty to set their students up to be
successful contributors to society an
educator should have that freedom to
teach honest complete facts about
historical events like slavery civil
rights without their licenses and
livelihoods put at risk by the vague law
House Bill 1162 restores the ability to
provide diverse educational approaches
to instruction and curriculum that's
tailored to meet students needs our
students deserve that freedom to learn
they deserve to be partner with
education that helps them learn from the
mistakes of the past so they're better
prepared to
succeed and on behalf of Na New
Hampshire and our membership I
respectfully ask you find House Bill
1162 ought to pass and I will submit
electric test um electronic testimony
thank you very much are there any
questions represent
Woodcock good afternoon good afternoon a
quick question do you believe that um
your fellow Nea teachers um have backed
away from the how and wise sensus or do
you think they just saw said forget
about just gone on thank you for the
question I absolutely believe they have
backed away from it and part of the
lawsuit is a lot of those examples on
what teachers have not done and what
they've stopped doing from what they did
before and I I know I've submitted those
examples before as well welcome further
questions from the committee represent
laus thank you for taking my question do
you believe that there's a difference
between teaching that somebody believes
that um let's take one example that
whites are better than blacks or that is
different or the same as teaching that
there are people who believe that black
whites are better than blacks thank you
for the question I do believe there's a
difference but what is happening with
this law is educators are so afraid
teachers are so afraid that they're
going to lose their license over this
they're going to lose their livelihood
and when you have that consequence as
part of a law that's I'll be honest
vague I mean that's what the lawsuit is
about and we ask for clarification on
what couldn't couldn't be taught
specifics from the Department of
Education and from the Attorney
General's office and never received any
answers and so
what's happening is you know I've been
asked many times in this committee what
is vague about it and the the problem is
it it just truly is vague educators are
too afraid that something's going to
happen they'll be brought up on an
investigation it's going to get through
social media they're going to be dragged
through the mud their their potential of
losing their livelihood their license to
teach is what's stopping them from
teaching some of the things that this
part people have said that they could
still
teach thank you very
much thank you thank you I like to call
Maya
angelbert hello my name is m Mia long
time no see um I yeah I might not be a
lawyer or a teacher or anything like
that but like everyone else in this room
I have been a student and I would like
to tell a story um when I was in school
I learned like most of you that
Christopher Columbus sailed the ocean
blue in
1492 in high school I learned there was
more to the story than that I learned
about how he took the natives as slaves
how he subjugated them how he stole the
natural resources of the West Indies and
brought them back to
Spain and I don't think that students
could learn that sort of thing nowadays
because it makes some people feel
uncomfortable
and also history isn't just a set of
facts it it's a series of events that
relate to each
other that what happened in the past is
directly related to what's happening
today and we need the historical context
to understand current world
um I feel like I'm just rambling but the
point is I think students can be trusted
with not just facts but how to interpret
those
facts uh not how to interpret those
facts I can learn how to interpret those
facts in a way that supports their own
worldview with facts and logic and yeah
I yeah I'm definitely rambling but thank
you for listening to me thank you very
much Maya are there questions from the
committee thank you for coming today uh
sure he good afternoon chairman lad glad
to be back here uh my name is Deborah H
I'm here with the American Federation of
teachers New Hampshire and uh just f
osure we also have a lawsuit against the
so-called divisive Concepts law um we
also don't know when the ruling will
come down on that but uh we'll keep you
uh informed anyway I am here today on
behalf of our 3700 members across the
state and all the public school students
that we uh educate in support of HB
1162 and um the main reason we are
supporting this is as has been so um a
really testified to
already the divisive Concepts law is one
we didn't need it was a problem we
didn't have we didn't have public school
teachers teaching any curriculum in the
state that was uh instructing students
that anyone was inherently Superior or
inferior to anyone else it just wasn't
going on as a curriculum if there were
individual instances they should have
been handled uh through the local
disciplinary
procedures so that was casting a broad
net and taring all of our Educators in
the State uh with allegations that
something was going on in schools that
just wasn't happening um getting rid of
that law would really be a relief
because the effect of this law this
divisive Concepts law has been
to make the education all Republic scho
school students are getting
worse they are not receiving the rich
robust instruction in history that they
deserve the teachers are concerned
about
teaching in ways where students are able
to connect events to each other to go
beyond just the straightforward here are
the who what and why and make
connections between what happened in the
past and how they relate to each other
and what's happening now um you have
language arts teachers who are concerned
about teaching specific novels they have
already taught in the past they've
always taught in the past a middle
school teacher who has always taught to
Kill a Mocking Bird has not assigned it
since this law is passed she is afraid
of losing her license because she does
not want to be brought up on um a
complaint under this law even though
it's been part of the curriculum in the
past and uh there's been exactly one
complaint filed under this law since it
was passed one
so if this is such a problem that we
need a law against it how come there's
only been one complaint I do ever in
testimony and it will pass that around
very much thank you very much other
leus you said and we've heard from
others that we're brushing teachers with
a broad Stroke by this law that somehow
we're saying that all teachers are
bad and I'm wondering if we pass law
that says people should not steal are we
then brushing all people with a brush
that says all people are bad because we
passed a law saying what people
shouldn't
do you don't have to answer questions
yeah I I don't think that really is a
serious question so thank you yeah are
further questions from the
committee thank you for coming
today with that we have no more pink
cards up here and we're going to close
1162 we'll come back and start the next
1:15 I'll be watching it on Saturday
after
so we have more of this right after hi
how you doing I just want to find a
scribble Cofe before I pass the rest I
think we need to have a lunch and relax
okay at least I do I got enough stress
ins oh because she wants to get someone
to uh cut a St tape out and post she
media
what
com
e
it's um a little bit after the appointed
start time but uh we'll move on to the
uh hearing for House Bill
1671 relative to the process for
teaching discrimination and allowing
Educators and school school officials a
right of action for damages and costs
for false accul accusations and uh call
Bill thank you Mr chair um for the
record I'm representative Linda Tanner I
represent Sullivan 5 District 5 uh the
beautiful towns of Springfield and cipy
and
um this bill that I did in September
um uh has two issues basically within
the bill uh first um it's the code of e
ethics um IT addresses the code of
ethics used as a a weapon um that it was
not meant to be nor should be used as a
sticker of punishment for intimidating
investigating or threatening the loss of
a teaching credential for what how
teachers teach uh the committee that
wrote the code never meant to punish
teachers for doing their job and then
the second part uh that I tried to
address was I tried to give a Band-Aid
for teachers who are wrongly accused and
investigated as well as boost morale by
providing a bill that was meant to help
teachers
um I did this bill back in September and
I have to be honest that as I looked at
the bill last week when I was getting
ready for this um that the first part of
it with the Band-Aid
part um is not written the way I would
really like it to be written it isn't
precise enough it doesn't it's kind of
vague and uh leaves a lot of loose ends
um but the second part of the bill the
part about the code of ethics um I think
is still really important and that's why
I'm here presenting this bill um and
um you know my my intent was to stop and
reverse the trend of unreasonable
unfounded attacks on public education
and
teachers which uh demoralizes threatens
those currently in the classroom with
the loss of their livelihood and
dissuades those seeking to enter the
profession therefore I'm offering an
amendment uh which I put on your desk um
Amendment
0499 um which is going to uh replace the
bill and really focus on the code of
ethics and the New Hampshire code of
ethics I was around when it was uh
developed it was had a really nice
Commission of a lot of stakeholders and
it was meant to provide professional
Educators with guidance for all and all
School Personnel um and it was laid out
so that it would be well understood and
and easy to kind of easy to follow and
then as it progressed after it came in
and uh it seemed like it popped up in
various laws as the last little stick
that you know this um this bill if you
violate this bill um it it's considered
a violation of the code of ethics in
fact we find we got a technical advisory
this morning that just about set me off
the roof um from the Department of
Education about the code of ethics um
involved with teachers talking to
students outside of health and sex ed
classes uh which if you haven't read yet
you should anyway um as you can see this
this amendment what the amendment does
is it takes this the same language from
the code of ethics so the code of ethics
uh the New Hampshire code of ethics for
professional Educators shall establish
guidance for all School personnel and
then the addition really is and shall
not
be uh in the code of ethics it says it
is not intended for but I Chang that to
shall not be the basis for civil
liability nor basis for employment
action and then the last sentence again
is something that I added further the
code shall not be used to limit or
restrict the Educator's use of pedagogy
or curriculum approved by the local
school board and that sometimes
conflicts with there's all kinds of con
conf conflictions with
different
um state laws federal laws Schoolboard
decisions that sort of thing um I don't
think sometimes people realize how hard
it is
um for people who have worked in schools
um for the teachers that come to testify
or those Educators listening to this
committee meetings to sit and listen to
being disrespected accusations inuendos
about our competency or
professionalism
um it to spend hours listening to the
persistent drone of bills based on
problems that don't exist on incomplete
misinformation or unfounded antidotes
taken out of
context on a distorted focus on student
underachievement and hear a total
mistrust and dis disrespect for
educators in the public school and then
have the professional code of ethics
used against us we have dedicated our
career to public education to teaching
and helping students grow we know the
hard work and dedication that actually
goes on into teaching every day in the
classrooms around our state we know the
skills needed to meet the chall
challenges and responsibilities with 30
or more Elementary children in a
classroom all day or work with 100 or
150 middle school or high school
students each day we know what it's like
to be that trusted adult for students to
celebrate their joy and in the tough
times their sadness we know the
challenges we set before our students
and see them succeed and reach those
goals and
Beyond I'm proud of all our public
school students teachers and staff and
thank them educat are professionals and
they needed to be treated as such so
that's the basis for my Amendment and
Bill thank you thank you uh questions
for representative Tanner uh
representative
lakas thank you and thank you for taking
my question sure my question has to do
with the nor a basis for employment
action and my understanding was that the
very end of the code of ethics and
conduct section the parts did have to do
with
employment was reserved for very gross
misconduct such as sexually assaulting a
student and if we take that out can we
still use that this is this is still
here um there's still a section in
statute about dismissal of teachers um
when I first started teaching I was told
that it was
incompetence uh insubordination and
immoral behavior that those were the
general categories that were left I
would you know I would assume um and I
probably shouldn't assume but in law we
have 21 different violations which uh if
a person if that pops up in their
criminal background checks are
ineligible so I would assume those
affect employment as well um and
educators are supposed to
reveal um if that happens if they
get um criminally charged for any of
those things um and usually the public
knows before the everybody else knows so
um yes this is this is like I said the
only change in this particular sentence
is that uh the shall not instead of not
intended to be and the last uh sentence
about the pedagogi and curriculum
approved by local school boards
representative
Miler thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here since most of the committee
was not
here um on this committee when the code
of conduct was created could you give us
a brief history of how that was created
and who were the persons involved in the
creation of the code of contract and the
reason for I wish I had a copy of it
right with me maybe somebody has one but
um it was was it was made to be a code
of ethics and a code of conduct and
there was a commission formed to study
it uh with all the stakeholders teachers
go thank you thank you very
much um so excuse me so it's this book
and uh my Drew Klein was the was the um
chairman who's also the chairman of the
State School Board
um or that's actually the state school
board that's not what I
wanted I thought I had listed the
Commission in
here H the committee the committee
commissioner's task force on Educators
ethics membership so it had somebody
from the chapter of American Federation
of teachers um which we hear from uh
Christina uh from the New Hampshire
State School boards Association uh Carl
lad from the New Hampshire School
administrators Association Dean cascaden
from the New Hampshire superintendent
Association uh Diana Fenton who we see
periodically from the Department of
Education Diana Terell New Hampshire
State Board of Education Professional
Standards Board um the late dougl
aft uh Frank Hull New Hampshire Council
for teachers education CTE Gail Adams
Davis New Hampshire Association for
School principles Helen H honoral New
Hampshire State Board of Education Irv
Richardson National Education
Association uh Kimberly yarla PSP P
public
school what is
it professional standard board thank you
um it's nice to have the Greek chorus
behind me um Laura was lski CTE Lorraine
Hampshire schle administrators okay um
Michael Perez New Hampshire Association
School principls Nancy Morris Nea no he
him Mark he Mark New Hampshire doe at
the time Phil Littlefield New Hampshire
school associ uh superintendent
Association Suzanne Canali CTE Virginia
Clifford New Hampshire doe so um as you
can see it was a large Comm
uh task force it was uh had the
stakeholders in it um I think they spent
a lot of time on it a lot of effort um
and it was a it was it is a good um book
for teachers and for people that are in
the field of Education it was never
intended never
intended to be put into statute as a VI
as um punishment or a stick for
um
statutes uh r m thank you thanks for
taking my question do you know if the
code of eics is readly available to
Educators in public non-public and
chartered Public Schools um this is
online I believe with the Department of
Education um and we had a whole bunch of
them that were handed out um and I don't
know if we still have any of these
around or
not here yes we we have any more of
these here in this office um we unloaded
all those um but they were handed out to
teachers as well okay they're made
available so through the Department of
Education thank you and hopefully when
they get credential they get a copy
that's when they get it yeah yep further
questions uh seeing none thank you very
muches I hope you can support
this I
think representative maybe we can get a
card from you and were there any other
cards for this no you need a
card res
y
okay so there are no more cards here so
we're going to close the hearing down on
1643 I'm gon have to look at my last
it I think I retired it with it not
intentionally I just had too much stuff
to carry around i' like to read it too I
on also on this other
what
speaking
[Music]
oh
no
prob
oh okay
sorry
I think I'm going to have to start
putting I had just now
remembered what I had figured out works
when I get like this is to put um
to one a particular variety
account not as as
yesterday well I was thinking I usually
couch and I'd forgotten about doing
it do get home
t
I bring
it here and see if defitely on The
Struggle Bus and if it does I'll wrap it
up and put it in my drawer until I can
take it or throw it away or whatever I
home
okay it's uh 6:47 or so um
excuse 147 totally different SI a long
day um so uh we're on 164 three
requiring school districts to make
curriculum and instructional materials
available on their web
pages and let's
see we have no reps represent leus would
co-sponsor
Alicia leus Hillsboro 38 Hudson and
1643 requiring school districts to make
curriculum and instructional materials
available on their web
pages um I think when I at one point
when I was a teacher this would have
been
complicated because I did lots of
handouts that I did up and moted off but
now we have computers and so
now not only do I think it would be much
simpler than it used to be but I also
have always
appreciated those teachers who posted
those things on the web pages every day
or at least weekly what they were going
to be do as a parent it helped me um
keep up with what my kids were doing and
make sure they got their work done and
that was really the biggest part for me
was making sure they were doing what
they were supposed to be doing and um I
know one of her teachers every day would
post this is what we
covered and given that I'd have been
doing my handouts based on the computer
would have been nothing for me to upload
it and it's not even asking for this as
a daily it's saying at the end of the
year
but I appreciate when teachers do this
on their website on a regular basis
cuz it just helps with that
communication and with let's face it
most kids don't like doing their
homework so it helps that's that's all I
have to
say thank you are you willing to take
any
questions I can try okay let me start
out with one the title of the bill deals
with to make curriculum and
instructional materials available on
their web page PES mhm I go into the
bill itself and I see you're referencing
the bill references in line six
instructional
material but
what the
curriculum are they how much are they
supposed to be putting on the web page
here this curriculum all these textbooks
and just just what they are I mean if
you go down further you go ahead you
would say the name the book published by
and the whatever version you're using
you don't have to have you're not even
supposed to put because most of that is
copyrighted you're not going to put that
on the website you're just going to say
we're using this book like I used a
particular math book that the school
provided so I would have just said this
math book and then any additional stuff
that I did which I did a lot of I would
have posted
did sorry okay any further questions
represent McDonald thank
you what you just explained in terms of
the books used not necessarily the book
itself sounds similar to me to like a
college syllabus is that kind of the
intent of this that's my understanding
okay thank you representative Tanner
thank you I'm I'm going to talk about
the lesson plan part of
this um and ask some questions and give
some comments I guess first of all um
this sounds something like I had in
student teaching when they were right on
my back and to know what I was doing
every minute of the day um as an
experienced teacher I didn't I didn't do
this okay um and so H I don't know what
you're digging for I guess that's that's
um maybe the first question what's your
intent with this what are you digging
for when you ask for for procedures for
documentation review approval of lesson
plans when you um talk about uh volumes
the volumes of lesson plans from the
year um and identify the teacher uh in
part section two part
a um I'm not entirely sure what all of
this was what the intent was I
co-sponsored it because I thought there
were some good ideas in it but not
because I understood completely the
intent when it was filed so I can't say
that
um I was looking at it not so much as a
record at the end of the year as an
ongoing as a communication between
parents and teachers is a easy way of
communicating what we're working on and
so I wouldn't I mean as a teacher if I
assign a particular homework assignment
in the book I would put that there so
that the parent knows okay this is
what's expected and they can get on
their student and say is it done right I
mean I know I did that once we got to
this online thing and my granddaughter
was living with me for her four years of
high school I looked to see what the
assignments were and was she doing it um
and I that's what I was looking at
myself but the other part of that I know
parents want to
know what's being taught
so so again you would put if you use
particular books you'd put the books so
that they would know as far as at the
end of the
year I actually don't know I follow up
on that please yes go ahead so the other
thing about lessons lesson plans and I'm
sure you you experienced this as well is
that you the best laid plans don't work
out and not only do do they not work out
but a good teacher has a toolkit to
bring up other things and and work
around that um and yet this is the type
of legislation that I feel parents want
to know each and every little thing that
you do and then it's kind of a got you
if you don't do it or a got you if you
do do it so um I was just wondering if
if I made a lesson plan for next Monday
and next Monday rolls around and it's
snow sow day or next Monday rolls around
and all of a sudden the kids can't
figure out what I'm trying to tell them
so I'm trying to revise the plan and
move around how does how do I have to
submit a new plan that's that's reviewed
and approved um before I can do anything
B I think at that level I mean nobody
looked at every plan every handout I
made I was always making handouts and
quizzes and everything to try to get my
kid you know so I could see how they did
and that would happen daily based on how
they where they were what they
understood what they needed more
practice
in and I think where it comes for that
is if you're planning on like I used the
book and we
had by Department
that these things would be done by these
times Etc I think that's what that's
overall
um and the the plans I
mean if I had had access to a website
which I didn't when I was teaching
math I would have and I would have done
what the science teacher that my
granddaughter had was at the end of each
day put on there what we had
done and not in advance but at the end
of each day because my papers would have
been done on the computer and I could
have just uploaded
them fur further questions
Woodcock afternoon R lakas um I have a
concern when I read when I read the
depth of bread of this bill I don't know
when teachers are going to do it at the
end of the day they're beat let take a a
science teacher with five sections to
five different preps in a high school
they run that every single day it seems
like an enormous amount of work for
limited value I mean they get it Mo a
lot of teachers have their own websites
particular in the middle in elementary U
you can see some of the text they're
using but to put their day by day by day
lesson plans and and and if the things
happen to change for the youngster ask
question that grabs you that that's way
it goes you why had out here I'd be
petrified well I didn't do the thing I
was supposed to do cuz on the plan I
just think this is uh it's almost like a
big brother watching and and a second
hand it's
like in the back of my head I'm thinking
well I'm giving you all the stuff I do
in public school you can take it and do
it at home or you can take it and do in
your child school after I've done all
the work here's all the stuff you can do
and that scares me so I I just think
this is a huge burden on on teachers
time time wise sex wise I mean in terms
of the text M I don't have a problem
with that uh putting it out there but
they give out syllabus at least in high
school that's all I'm familiar with they
give out syllabus to the start of the
class that has those things we're not
going and I wouldn't want my students
parents to tell High School youngster
check your homework check your homework
check your homework and we're trying to
build maturity in these kids the next
day John you check your homework we got
a problem here now now we start that
communication we start to build what'
you miss I just I like the concept in
terms of the thinking behind it
represent but Bo I would I can never a
support this just like the big brother I
I I think whether how much or whether or
not you have to ask your child to check
their homework depends upon the child
certainly I would have never asked my
oldest if he did his homework or what it
was he was generally so far ahead of the
school I didn't worry about it but I did
have kids who I did have to check every
day or they did not do their homework
and they did not do well and so having
it
available I mean if I didn't have to
check my kid I wouldn't be spending my
time as a parent going on and looking
but if I did it was a very nice resource
one of the teachers did it but as I
said it was easy it would I had to do
these Pages up anyways so just to upload
a copy of it would have been you know
almost no when I send it to PR I can
upload it at the same time it's not
like I'm doing a lot it's online and
it's just upload the file no big
deal I understand I understand the
upload of the documents I understand the
books I don't I don't understand the
amount of time in terms of what you
think is available for teachers if
you're an English teacher you have to go
home and correct or rewrite and help
edit now they do it on the computer and
the do document they have hours to do it
afterwards why and God's neighb they
want want to be put spend doing this is
just going to be up on a website they're
trying to work with kids instructionally
honestly I just think this is way too
much for teachers to
do further questions from the committee
representative Cornell Thank you thank
you for taking my question this says it
has a local fiscal note that was the
department was asked for on no October
10th any idea of how much it local no
idea why it costs anything this is
another downshifting to the local of
another cost it may
be
I mean they're supposed
to
um have a collective software document
or spreadsheet to
allow up you know to update so I think
that I mean a Google doc I would think
could just take care of that and as a
teacher okay I've done my thing now I
have to print it I just send a copy to
Google Docs it's done I spend much more
time creating that thing than to just
send it
off but but we don't know yeah I there's
a lot I no I don't
know were there further questions from
the committee thank you very
much um me um are either the new Aire
School boards Association or School
administrator Association interested and
saying
anything uh good afternoon House
Education committee chairman lad thank
you for taking my testimony today we
are
fault uh Becky Wilson for the New
Hampshire school boards Association uh
we are opposed to this bill
um last year some of you may recall
there was a very similar bill in terms
of posting curriculum to the website of
the school district which we also uh
opposed at that time first we would uh
say that RSA 186 colon 11 uh Roman
numeral 9-c already requires school
districts to make curriculum course
materials available to parents or
Guardians for review upon request um so
certainly while we would not um like to
suggest that right to know request be
put in every time someone wants to look
at something from the school district
that's already covered under the right
to know law and can be publicly viewed
by anyone who wants to put in that
request um we would however just suggest
that a concerned parent or an individual
speak with the school superintendent and
set up a time to go in and look at
whatever the material or instructional
uh materials and curriculum that are
being used are viewed between the parent
and the superintendent um I would like
to speak to the fact that there's a very
big difference between posting a
homework blog of what assignments are
due the next day or that week most
teachers do that already if they are
teaching at an age where there's
required instruction and homework that
is available that is very different than
what the intention it seems of this bill
is uh this bill requires much more than
that it requires it seems that the
lesson plans of every teacher in every
classroom for every block that they
teach be posted on the website um not
only for the current year but for the
year prior
um so that that is an extraordinary
number of lesson plans I was just doing
some quick math in the back I went on
the doe website and because I was
watching their deliberative session last
night Windham has 338 Educators um if
those people teach four periods a day
which is small compared to what most
teachers would teach at a high school
could be up to eight periods a day um
five days a week that's about 1352
lesson plans a day for that district and
6,000 per week
6,760 uh if you go to school for 36
weeks that's about 250,000 lesson plans
per year with no straying from what you
have created for that day's lesson um if
you have strong Educators who are doing
formative assessment during the class
and changing up the lesson plan I'm not
sure you could be doing four or five
lesson plans per period so you could
multiply that times five or 10 or
whatever you want to do um so this bill
is really focused on paperwork and
administrative tasks not really the art
of teaching or any pedagogy um a list of
books is not descriptive of what
curriculum or instruction is so while I
appreciate if that's what the intent of
this bill is for then it should just say
a list of books it shouldn't talk about
curriculum and instructional materials
while I appreciate that the sponsors at
this bill tried to Define that it's
still very vague um I don't know if it
applies to students who are on an IEP
who potentially have individualized
instruction blocks are there are their
uh instructional materials going to be
posted online for people to look at that
seems like it could be concerning um so
I would just the last point I would make
is very important to consider whether
the district even has the storage
capability technology-wise to manage
this bill um I understand that it seems
like it might not be um a cost to the
district on its face but I will tell you
that storage especially with information
that is related at all to students um
you has to be kept at a very high level
um last year's Bill I know that's not
what we're talking about said well we'll
just combat this problem by offering the
district could hold it all physically
somewhere but if you go back to the
example I just gave that's you know half
a million lesson plans for two years
where are you housing that online or
otherwise um so there's absolutely a
fiscal impact to your local District um
it may even involved having to hire more
Tech staff just to do that um teachers
are not uploading their documents as
they make them according to this bill
because they have to be vetted by some
sort of admin process each lesson plan
has to go through some sort of approval
process that is posted also on the
website um and lastly the bill does
create what appears to be a possible
Statewide lesson plan template that
would come from the Department um I'm
not sure if that's something that
would make people more or less
comfortable um and the effective date is
July one of this coming year but it
requires last year's lesson plans to be
posted so how are you expecting
districts to comply with this if it goes
into effect on July 1 we're already in
February so where are this past
semester's lesson plans I'm happy to
take questions I got a question for you
um having been a a teacher Becky you uh
I asked ask
you in looking at lesson plans
especially when you were in the area of
special
education did you ever in your lesson
plan book said today I'm going to meet
with a small group and we're going to be
dealing with whatever is on that
IEP uh so there's a reference to how
many times you had the contacts and all
that is there any confidentiality to
that lesson plan thank you for the
question yes is the very short answer to
that often times again when I was
educator um I ran a program for students
with emotional behavioral disorders so
those students had some similar needs
some different we ran lots of social
skills groups which targeted certain uh
emotional and social needs that those
students needed to work on you could you
needed to keep track of that in terms of
your compliance with Federal um idea
regulations in terms of making sure
you're meeting Services Etc and tracking
students progress but of course um you
know the names of who are in those
groups or what you're working on Etc
that would not ever be something that
you would want a special educator be
posting
online thank you further
questions thank you very
much all rep
Le sorry thank you I'm reading and
rereading and trying to put all this
together
and a number of people have talked about
lesson plan is in that thing you write
up as to what you hope to accomplish
that
week
and here it seems like it's a past tense
lesson time the instruction
provided um of all instructions assigned
distributed Etc
so am I reading it wrong I see it as a
past tense as opposed to a what you were
planning on doing so maybe lesson plan
is not the right
term uh thank you for the question I
wouldn't want to try to Define what the
sponsors of this bill meant by lesson
plan I don't know what the intention is
of having to post the lesson plan
because I'm not really clear as you said
on what what it is that's being posted
if it is a
syllabus that or a list of materials
that's very different than what an
educator would call a lesson plan that's
that's what I was wondering thank you
thank you further questions thank you
welcome thank you Mr chairman Jerry
FW associate executive director of the
New Hampshire school administrators
Association and I'm here today to
express our our opposition and concerns
with this particular piece of
legislation uh the first thing that came
to mind in reading the the title an act
requiring school districts first
question that came to mind was should
schools to make curriculum and
instruction materials available that was
uh the first question in um line seven
there's reference to other reading
materials and I'm sure that those of you
uh who have been in classrooms and in
education circles uh might be familiar
with the fact that in many Elementary
School classrooms and Middle School
classrooms teachers have classroom
libraries available for kids to choose a
book read a book during you know rest
time or downtime or wind time or anytime
uh and so was this include listing all
of the materials in those classroom
libraries that are accessible and
available for kids uh to look at uh line
21 lesson plans used during the prior
school year just the question is what is
the purpose of that uh it seems to be an
an
honorous uh administrative burden uh and
teacher burden to
include I just don't know what the what
the purpose of including the previous
year's lesson plans would be uh it's
already difficult uh in a timely way to
to do a an an on time or in time lesson
plan
uh make sure I hit
everything I do want to appreciate
representative leus acknowledgement of a
hard work the teachers do to kind of
Keep Their Heads above water every day
um it's not an easy business it's not
like when I won't speak for you all when
I was in school um I think it was a
simpler time and my teachers worked real
hard and some of them worked real hard
just to get me through their
coursework um and and thank goodness
that there wasn't a parent portal on the
web where my parents could go in and see
whether I got my homework done or not or
how I done on a test or a quiz because
that's the current reality folks parents
can access grades they can access course
materials they can access lesson plans
they can access what's going on in the
classroom it's included in program of
studies it's included in in it's access
for anyone who wants to pick the fruit
the fruit is there for the picking and I
think it's important to acknowledge the
hard work that teachers put into to
having that done already we don't need a
state law to to to have a gotcha with
you didn't get this requirement done you
didn't get that piece done and so we're
going to sanction you somehow um this is
local work and local if a local school
board wants their teachers to post
things on the web then they can say we
that this is an expectation of
employment in the school district we
want you to do this um it has collective
bargaining implications uh this is a lot
of work and all due respect it will cost
money and there's no money in here to
help uh help support this particular
additional work teachers are going to
have to take additional time to upload
things and I won't I won't uh restate
the things that that Becky uh talked
about in terms of storage space and all
those things that become then District
problems to to mitigate um High School
teacher could have several preps in each
day and you're going to differentiate
and personalize instruction do all of
those pieces have to be posted on the
web where do you want teaching where do
you want time to go meeting
bureaucratic uh regulations and laws
passed down by the state of New
Hampshire or do you want it to be
invested in teaching and learning with
children and Remediation and supporting
their individual needs because there are
only so many hours in the day folks and
oh by the way if that teacher in that
classroom advises a club or a or uh
coaches a sport they then may have to
contact based on another piece of
legislation that you heard this morning
they may have to go home and call
parents to see if their if their
nickname kid you know flash or Sparky if
they have permission to call the Kid
Flash or Sparky so when is when does all
this get done there are only so many
quality hours in the day don't know
about you all I get tired at the end of
the day thankfully the teaching
profession has wonderful people they
used to working 12 hours a day I can't
do that at my age anymore it's it's it's
tough um people work really hard and I
think that we have to be mindful of the
fact of what we already asked them to do
tests and quizzes are instructional
materials ises that does this mean it
says instructional materials have to be
posted tests and quizzes are going to be
posted on the web as well this says
instructional materials those are
instructional materials so I think this
is well- intended I also um would bring
to the attention that three of the
sponsors of this bill are from the North
country and I find it um puzzling that
an observation that three of those
sponsors represent the North Country
probably the region least equipped to
have curriculum directors and additional
teachers that have time to review things
they don't have curriculum and we
experience that right now we have a
group of curriculum and and instruction
assessment folks from the state we don't
have anybody on the North country that
can afford one hour a month to come to a
meeting to get support in curriculum
instruction and assessment from their
colleagues how the heck can we ask those
small School principles because that's
where it's going to land to enter all of
this information on behalf of their
teachers or to support their teachers
you know and I I cite another small and
then I'll stop promise Mr chair um I'll
site the the commun the small community
of Hill okay only because I'm familiar
with the
situation Brian connley is a
superintendent he's the principal for a
while he was a special education
director for a few days he was the cook
because the cook got injured and
couldn't come to work and so then you're
going to say oh by the way Brian you've
got to interrupt you know if your
teachers aren't aren't uh available or
able to enter their curriculum materials
guess what briy good luck now you're
you're an administrative assistant for
yourself so I think that this is the
transparency of knowing what kids are
doing in school is available to people
now as they as they want to choose it uh
and I'm not quite certain that um this
bill serves any great purpose if you if
you support
um if you support increasing the burden
on teachers and administrators and
taxpayers then you'll support this bill
if you feel that the energy of teachers
and administrators need to be put into
kids and instruction and learning and
you're serious about not wanting to
increase burden on local taxpayers
having to pay for the increased cost due
to the implementation of this then
you'll find this bill inexpedient to
legislate thank you thank you I have one
question for you Jerry um a as a past
principal as a past teacher we had a
little book called The the plan
book and in the plan book we put down
what we were doing whether it was
reading math social studies whether
reading about ell wazelle the Holocaust
or book night or whatever it was put
down in there are you saying that this
is this still being being done in
schools I've been out there since 2004
out of it but I would assume that this
is being done by teachers still thank
you Mr chairman for that question yes
extensive planning is taking place in
the part of teachers and unlike my
teaching experience when I might say I
taught four High School classes of
social studies very different levels
senior Theory political Theory down to
New Hampshire history and government
level four when everything was leveled
they were very different pieces of my
day um and the plan book would would be
very cryptic for lack of a better term
you know two or three words cover this
topic today teachers have much more
extensive planning that they illustrate
what technology they're using what
competencies they measuring that day um
you know the administrators have to have
planned observations and walkthroughs
and the administrative burden has
increased so uh all due respect Mr
chairman the plan books that you and I
fill out in our days of teaching they
belong in the museum these days is it
safe to say is it safe to say though in
the left hand drawer the right hand
drawer there is a plan book for when the
teacher is absent for The Substitute
Teacher there's a stack of plans like
that when a teacher is absent for a
substitute teacher so plans are
occurring yes sir that's what I'm trying
to say further questions represent Miler
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony Dr
FW um you've outlined a fairly rigorous
program that current teachers are and
I'm assuming that is based on your
previous role as a as a
teacher as a principal as an assistant
principal as a
superintendent so you've seen the all
the levels that have gone through and
it's based upon that experience that you
have that you view this bill as being
much more intrusive to the learning and
instruction process based on your
education experience thank you
representative for that question and yes
that is correct thank
you any further
questions thank you very much is this on
this other bill came this on this one on
Horgan
done okay thank you I just
uh I I anyway I like a few few pretty
severe RIS few sever reservations of
Bill one thing that's common to a lot of
these bills is uh talks about what the
school board is supposed to do um there
are public charter schools and guess
there's other other school and there
similar schools that don't have a school
board I guess usually we tend to
interpret these bills to mean that the
board of the Charter Public Schools
stands in place of the school board if
it's unless it's a Charter Public School
which has a school board with some do so
that's one um that's one big ambiguity
in this um also like the lesson plans
not every kid child in the classroom is
necessarily following the exact same
lesson plan they often have customized
materials cuz for children who either
you know either either need need help
getting up to the grade level or are
above the grade level so there isn't
necessarily just one lesson plan
although that's probably and also um
there's licensing issues with the
contents a lot this most of this content
is is copyrighted um so they you know we
may not
even some publisher educational
Publishers might not even want to let us
use materials here in New Hampshire if
they can put them in a website where
like anybody can you know look at it
pirated copy Etc and
um also and this is probably by Design
but it seems to be set up so anybody can
object to what's being taught in the
school even if their child is not in
school if they're not otherwise directly
involved and I suppose I can see the r
now where the taxpayer dollars are
paying for it but that could be a lot of
problem you could have somebody who's
you know doesn't have a child in the
school you know isn't a you know maybe
not doesn't even live in the school
district uh taking up the school board's
time or the chartered or presumably the
chartered schools uh board's time um you
know on disputes which maybe don't
really have
anything because they're upset about
material like even though they really it
doesn't really directly affect them at
all what's being taught in the classroom
so um I
think I think this uh I think this bill
is just looking at it seems poorly
thought and it goes too far so certainly
um if you do try to pass it you need you
probably need to address just some of
the issues I've thought of in many
others which I hadn't thought of because
I'm just
uh I just signed up for speak to two
minutes and uh you know on the fly so I
didn't he any prepared remarks so I
think this uh Bill certainly should not
be passed in its current form if it is
passed it needs pretty uh pretty major
changes I would suggest either it owning
it or sending it sending it to interim
study and in any case uh what's being
taught at school is certainly not a
secret from the uh child and hence it's
not a secret from the parents so I'm not
sure like
uh I'm not really sure who else who else
um so I'm not really sure like who else
is directly involved in it that even you
know should be objecting to it espec I
mean certain especially if it meets the
curriculum standards so that's uh that's
why I think this bill is that's why I
think this bill is a bad idea so I just
uh just put in my two cents and say you
should you should we've not pass it so
thanks I happy to take any questions
thank you are there any questions for
represent Horgan yeah thank you very
much thank you we do not have any other
cards so we're closing this hearing and
we're going to move on to the next bill
which we have before us which is 12:30
12:35 yeah 12:35 relative high school
members
welcome
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you members of the committee uh my
name is David rord I'm from Grafton
one uh from the great town of Littleton
and Littleton has the
distinct uh recognition of being the
largest town north of the notch we're
not a city we we have the city uh but
the largest town north of the Notch and
really it's even despite the fact that
we have the largest town we have some
problems that I think we're we're going
to hopefully address today um hb1 1235
was actually brought to me by a teacher
in the school um Mr Jeremy Brown who you
have a copy of a letter that he gave me
yesterday uh he came to me 6 months nine
months ago uh with a problem that
hopefully we can solve here today and it
revolves around the bill that that the
law that came out of here a few years
ago that put a a student on the school
board so the school boards are required
to have a student representative which I
know him and I both agree is a wonderful
opportunity for these kids um and it's
good for the school board to get
feedback from from the students to
understand really what they're doing but
in a small town like Littleton uh and I
say it's a large town the largest town
we have is a population 5,800 uh we have
our own high school but the problem that
we're having up there because the school
is so small we are having a problem
finding students enough students to to
fill this position uh when you take just
to give it to perspective my daughter
graduated from Littleton high school
last year in a class of 35 so uh it's
not a huge School uh but they do have
participation but in they want they have
desire for participation in this um but
the problem is we just don't have the
students to do it uh you know when you
take students who are active in sports
extracurriculars after school jobs um it
limits the ability uh it limits the pool
that we can draw off of and the reason
why is because it has one you know the
current law has one student
representative and they have to attend
all the meetings so if you have one
student who has to attend all the
meetings it kind of takes away from
their ability to take do Sports um uh
work etc um so if you look at the bill
uh what we've done here we worked with
him and this a lot this came from him
this came right from the the the the
teachers uh with a recommendation how to
make this better um and he proposed that
the student government shall determine
the number of student school board
members so it could be more than uh one
um but not more than three
uh up to a maximum of three and
establish procedures for each for each
of them to share the responsibilities
that are defined in paragraph 4 and then
the other thing that we change in this
is just the attendance that rather than
attending all board meetings uh they
have to attend at least one school
meeting per month during the regular
school year of course we know these
school boards meet year round um and
this this adds a little more flexibility
it makes it a little more friendly and
attractive for students to get involved
and uh it it's an opportunity that we
want to succeed but we've uh we think it
will succeed more likelihood of
succeeding with these changes so pretty
simple um and I entertaining questions
that that you might have thank you very
much representative cordelli uh thank
you thank you representative for being
here um um a little bit confused by a
few things in here um uh I gather from
what you said the intent is for a shared
uh
position um now uh a a school board can
like to have more than one student
representative so how would that work in
your
bill so the well the the point that he
wanted to do the the the the objective
he want to achieve is actually have this
student elected chosen by the school the
school council the student council the
student government within the school um
he thought that uh by by including the
student government in the process you
get a more you get a better
participation from the student body
rather than keeping it segregated to a
school board
followup question thank you um yeah on
line three it says that a student member
shall be chosen by the high school
student body but then on line seven the
change you make is that Student
Government shall determine the number of
school board members up to a maximum of
three so is the student is this school
board determining the number of student
Representatives on the board
um and it seems like there's a conflict
about who chooses the student
Representatives is it the high school
student body is in lines three and four
or is it the student government it's the
intent was the student government so I
think that the line three probably
should be updated to uh uh or line three
and four where the student body that
that probably needs to be changed to be
government more yes go ahead um okay
then down in um the uh line 16 and
17 um where talking about the duties of
a student School Board member
um if there are as indicated in lines 8
and nine up to three I guess who would
represent each one of the school board
members who could share that position um
would each one of the
shared Schoolboard members have to
attend at least one board meeting per
month so the intent was that uh at
least um I believe he defined that in
there but in speaking with him the other
day was that um the the intent was that
at least one of those student members
would attend at least one meeting per
month you know the the the constraint
that they had on every single
Schoolboard meeting was not attrac to to
attract students to participate in this
so you know what what he was you know
considering and and what his feedback
was you know if we could get at least
one meeting attended per month that
would attract more students into
this thank you further questions yes
representative Cornell thank you and
thank you for taking my question um I'm
confused on how this would work in
Manchester where we have four High
School schools so they each have a
student representative on the board so
there's four and I I think they take
turns attending the full meetings and
then the subcommittees are divided among
them so they can choose which one best
fits them but they are chosen by the
high school student body because each
senior class or junior class which every
year they're elected has 500 students so
they run for for the whole class if it's
just elected by the student
government the four class officers are
picking who they want to represent them
instead of the whole school student body
but if this lives gives up to three per
High School we'll have
12 or we won't have
enough I see where you're coming from
that yes yeah and again this was really
school specific to how fixing a need in
a small school whereas you know you got
the other end of the spectrum um there
but if we could and I'm not averse to
you know mean it's your it's your bill
now and and you know you know that I
think you know the need um if if this
committee can come up with some type of
resolution that can accommodate these
smaller schools where they're we're not
being able to fill those positions
because we're so small I mean you've got
the opposite problem in that um you know
you got to you don't have a problem you
don't you don't have a problem this bill
would not be a problem as written for a
school like yours where the bill as
written is a problem for smaller schools
like
mine further further
questions just rolling around my mind
right now how would this work in a
Cooperative School District where you
have many many districts and even with a
system where you might have a k through
eight and they tuition their high school
kids out to another
District
um would the district that's receiving
these tuition students in this
particular
case allow for a student to be on that
board of the receiving school if they're
from a district that's sending tuition
wise and if it's 20 miles away from the
school or 10 miles away from which may
happen yeah I I don't think the law
speaks to that now or or as as proposed
um you I think that that's uh even
though because you know as the law is
now I don't think that that addresses
that that
question are other
questions represent Damon thank you
thank you for taking my
question this could be me but I'm not
100% sure that the
language clearly states there will be at
least one it says up to a maximum of
three I mean maybe you can read line
three into four
to confirm that there will be at least
one member I and I have to say I'm
coming at this my first elected office
was junior in high school Schoolboard
member and I learned a lot from it could
so I think thatan I think the the the
one comes from line three a student
School Board member shall be chosen I
mean so so that's where you're defining
something has to you have to have one
there and then line uh Eight Is Where It
defines you know the upper limit of that
okay
see Roman one that's not here under this
says you can have one or
more it's it's not in this part of law
it's the first part of the law um so I'm
getting really confused on how this
whole scheme is going to
work so represent Damon you had the FL
I'm sorry but for Buton in no that's
quite right and actually I just wanted
to uh follow follow up on your prior
conver comment Mr chair and hear from
the
representative would it seem reasonable
that tuition students would be eligible
to be Schoolboard reps if they were
elected by the student body where
they're going to
school why does it matter that they're a
tuition student they're a student at
that
school I can't think of a reason why
that would
matter I mean the goal is to the goal is
to get students involved and and to be a
conduit of information from the students
to the the the school board so I don't
understand you know I don't I don't uh
you know I I don't see how that would be
a a problem any further questions
representative Cornell yes thank you um
the RSA now says one or more students
from among its members to be non-voting
members so doesn't it so do we need to
change it to say up to three when it
says one or more already in the
RSA the say already says one or more
yeah in a different section a different
part in Roman one in Roman one right
we're in Roman two
here I get her point though it already
says more than one so we don't have to
add that yeah and two because it already
says
it Becky do have something back there
that
can okay okay so and again if if if that
is adequate if that that addresses what
what he's looking at that I would also
but but I would also contend that 16 and
17 line 16 17 move through uh where
there's not a requirement for attending
every single board meeting year round um
you know that's another that's another
barrier to entry if you will so if if if
we're comfortable with paragraph one no
ran number one addressing the number
then I you we could keep that the way it
is but I would ask that the the the
committee keep 16 to 7 line 16 to 17
thank you all right any other questions
today y we already have a pink card for
you
Becky for the record uh Becky Wilson
director of governmental relations for
the New Hampshire school board
Association uh we are not taking a
position on this bill but I did want to
try to clarify I think some of the
questions and concerns that were coming
from the committee as well as um maybe
provide a little situational context
potentially that we've heard about over
the past year since the original bill
was passed so initially when this bill
was passed last session two sessions ago
they're starting to blur in my mind
quite honestly um The Challenge was that
or the intention of the bill was to
require that every High School in a
district had a student representative on
the school board and that that position
was an elected position it has been very
common practice for many years for
school boards to have student reps but
they not not all of the student reps
were elected by the student body they
were appointed or maybe they were
elected or maybe if you were the student
president you also were the student rep
so there was different ways of becoming
the student rep that bill clarified that
that position has to be an elected
position by a majority of the student
body so this bill I believe um doesn't
necessarily require that you have more
than one but if you wanted to have up to
three those would all need to be elected
positions so that and as you might know
we've talked about it before in
conjunction with the New Hampshire
school administrators Association we
have held three training for student
reps um over the past year or so
representing about 30 different School
boards about 50 student members and we
have heard from student Schoolboard reps
sometimes it is a challenge to balance
um the role with their other obligations
that's work Sports other after school
activities Family Life Etc um because
they are full members of the board other
than non- voting for many of them the
expectation is not that you're just
giving a board report and leaving the
board meeting the expectation is you are
a full member of the board other than
for certain exclusions non-public Etc
and that you just can't vote um so the
expectation for some of these students
is that they are remaining at the school
board meeting for the entirety of the
school board meeting some school boards
only meet once a month some meet every
other week some in some of the cities
have their regular meetings every other
week plus committee meetings so
depending on how districts are
interpreting this role and how the
student government is sort of outlining
this role you could have a student who
was at school board meetings many times
per month um so this would allow the
student government not
to uh appoint student reps but all that
all the student government would be
doing is determining the number of
elected positions I think and what that
would entail so if you want to run for
Student Schoolboard rep this is what
that means you go to one meeting per
month maybe it's the full meeting maybe
it's a committee meeting however the
student government wants to define the
role they aren't telling the individual
reps what they're supposed to be doing
if that helps with that um we also over
the past year since the original bill
was put into place have had an
occasional situation where student rep
would be unable to attend school
sponsored events and I will leave it at
that uh without getting into a lot of
context for some particular reason
however because they are an elected in
their elected capacity they are still
expected to go to Schoolboard meetings
that has created some some challenges
for those districts I I'm happy to
provide more General context if needed
the board can't exclude them from the
meeting because they are elected as part
of the school board at the same time
they are not maybe uh available to
attend school sponsored events so if you
had additional School Board reps that
are student reps this would give you
some flexibility in terms of how to
handle those situations and still meet
your obligation of having student voice
on the school board um
I I'm open to answer any other technical
questions thank you thank you for uh
helping us out with this um you
mentioned that you believe um lines uh
seven and eight um indicate uh the
number of elected rep
Representatives um but it that's really
a School Board responsibility to
determine the number of student
Representatives on the school board
isn't isn't it thank you for the
question not the way the current statute
is the current statute mandates that you
have to have one that is elected by the
student body and the way the spill is
written the student government is
deciding if you want more than one
elected position and what their role is
follow so basically this language is
superseding the will of the school board
who might say we want one one
representative for on the student on the
board but this is indicating um the
Student Government Can overrule that and
say they want up to
three thank you for the question when
the initial bill was put forward the
intent of that was to have student voice
on the school board it was not a
Schoolboard requested position so I
believe that the intent of this amended
language in this bill allowing the
student government to determine how many
people they want um would not be out of
line with the original intent of having
further questions represent Damon thank
you and thank you for your help with
this I was interpreting the uh
representative introducing the bill to
be suggesting that having more than one
student representative would not
necessarily be an increased number of
positions but more of a job
share or it could be either of those but
would you comment on the idea of two or
three students sort of holding a
position that they rotate so no single
one has to attend all the meetings thank
you for the question so currently there
are a number of school boards and
student bodies who have two School Board
Representatives I'm just going to use
that as an example often it is a Junior
and senior for lack of a you know better
criteria and the intention of that is
for the junior student to come in and
kind of understand and learn the role of
the student School Board member so that
when the senior person graduates they
can elect yet another Junior scho
student rep um and then the senior and
so forth so in some of those situations
what's currently happening in practice
is perhaps not both of those reps are
staying for the entire meeting perhaps
if one of them has something else the
other person is staying vice versa or
they have between the two of them
figured out how you know okay I'm going
to provide a school bull report for the
K to six and I'm going to provide a
student rep report for 7 to 12 what
however they've divied up it between the
two reps already um for towns and cities
that have more than one high school you
have already more than one rep because
you need to have one from each High
School this would allow each High School
to have additional members so that if
somebody were unable to attend the
meeting that particular High School's
voice wouldn't be silent at that
meeting further questions repres
laus
so do you think think that the lines 7
through n are necessary in order to
do um what
was what the intent of the bill is as
far as that part goes or do you think
the fact that it says one or more
students in SE in in the section one
before this is sufficient to cover that
thank you for the question I think that
the
section one that's not on here requires
a student School Board rep to be elected
I think without some clarification it
might be confusing as to what about if
there are more than one rep do they all
have to be elected are some of them
appointed what's the role of those
people so if you want it to be aligned
with the other language I
think and again I don't know the
sponsors of this bill specifically in
terms of what the intent was but it
seems to me the intent was to allow the
same process for these other additional
reps which would be they would be
elected and the student government is
running that election it's a you know
race with the student body and they are
electing those people and deciding who's
doing
what thank you further questions from
the
committee not see any thank you very
much thank you are there any other cards
on this one with that we're going to
hearing
go
[Music]
okay the next bill we have and the last
1616 it's relative to parental consent
for student participation Medicaid to
schools program representa cordelli is
here to present the
bill uh thank you Mr chairman and
honorable colleagues uh for the record
Glenn cordelli representing Tuftonboro
wolfboro and oy and the Beautiful Lakes
Region and uh I'll keep in mind that
this is the last bill of the day um but
this bill um is pretty simple in its
intent um uh I
think my goal with this bill is to give
uh parents more oversight in terms of um
what's going on with their children in
school uh
currently um if you take a look um at uh
the basic onepage Bill the section one
and section
two um section one is related directly
to Medicaid to schools and I've passed
out the uh latest um required uh
DHHS uh annual report on Medicaid to
schools and you can see in uh school
year
22 um we're talking about over $113
million in federal Medicaid
reimbursement to New Hampshire schools
so it's a healthy sum um and right now
it is required that uh written parental
consent is required in order to Bill
Medicaid but that's only required one
time um the intent here is that
whenever uh there is billing for a new
service as indicated by a um uh a
different um uh service code diagnostic
code that there would be written
consent uh and at the same time before
the service was offered was applied
there should be written consent from the
parent also to that
service uh so two things uh for the
service there has to be written consent
and for billing um there has to be
written
consent um the second part uh is already
in statute uh Roman 200 excuse me RSA
227a um also related to the consent of
parents and uh I just try and replicate
that requirement in this uh area of
Statute so that again uh parental
consent is required for each new service
based on the diagnostic billing
code uh so I think it is um pretty
simple in in that regard um
one reason I I started thinking about
this requirement was um testimony we had
um I believe it was last year or it
might have been the year before with um
Medicaid to schools and um there was
even testimony from the Department of
Health and Human Services that there had
been U parental consent um being
required
online um for the billing to take place
but due to a previous
change by a previous administration that
consent was eliminated and the
department was working to bring back
basically the required written consent
so I started thinking about you know do
we want
billing um or consent just one time and
then it's cart blanch to bill for or
offer any other services that student uh
possibly without the parents knowledge
so that was the Genesis of um uh putting
this legislation together so that
parents know about what uh is being uh
offered to their students in school in
terms of uh
services so I thank you are there any
questions from the committee yes
representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I actually have two
so one is to
clarify um it
references diagnostic
code I'm wondering if maybe that isn't
supposed to be procedure code you don't
bill for a diagnosis usually you Bill
for whatever procedure or service is
provided relative to a
diagnosis
um uh I'll take that under advisement um
I I did work in a medical center um for
uh a decade and um I was very familiar
with uh ICD then it was idc9 codes I
think now it's 11 12 who knows what it
is but um and I did talk to a former
nurse about this as well um and that's
when we agreed on diagnos diagnostic but
um you know we can look into procedure
codes as
well and then may I follow up yes so the
other um question was just to uh
confirm it sounds like your the bill is
requesting to consents one for the
parent or Guardian to consent to
whichever service it is right and then a
separate one to concept for it to be
correct
okay Miler thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question once again I see
here on line
16 that you're using the code of
conduct as a punitive measure is there a
that uh it it's um really just uh to uh
ensure that um the consent is being
obtained uh primarily because um it
wouldn't obtain excuse me pertain to um
uh to the billing necess possibly
possibly to the billing but when we see
that um the system is not actually
requiring that consent now um uh I
wanted there to be some uh some form of
um remediation or penalty if you will um
for the uh elimination of that which is
required by
law yes well on that I mean is isn't
there another alternative other than
using the code of conduct for example
School District could Implement
Progressive discipline for example
rather than using the code of conduct in
be
Alternatives other
Alternatives forther questions I do have
one in representative
casken on line 14 it says any AG
educator who orders refers prescribes
renders or provides services if the IEP
specifies goals and objectives for this
particular
student and the speech pathologist or
the
nurse goes ahead and prescribes some of
these
Services um is the IEP enough or do you
have to go back and every time you do
this do you have to get support or
parent
thank you you think I have know by now
would you um uh if it's required in the
IEP and and the parent has signed off on
that
IEP um you know then I think we could
make an adjustment there represent
cascaden I was thinking WR those same
lines if it's a 504 plan or an
IEP if there's a change an addition or a
deletion of a
service that team has to convene and get
parental
permission but the members on the team
are not privy who's a Medicaid student
or not that's all internal within an
office that connects um the students
name so an
educator can't just automatically call
the speech person and say I want that
student to have more time it doesn't
happen that way the parent has to be at
the table if there's a need for more
time then it's a team meeting and they
have to sign consent for that so I don't
know if you've got specific examples
that identify what additional consent
because students on Medicaid is
confidential
information so providers don't know
which students are Medicaid and which is
so I do you have any specific I do not
have any specific
information repres
leus my question is also with that
section Roman numeral 9 but my question
is what about an emergency situation is
that uh exception for what are you
looking at I was looking at an emergency
situation for instance
epipens um they there wouldn't
necessarily be prior parental consent
but it might but you wouldn't have time
to get it either right yeah I I I would
see that um emergency situations like we
talked about with that specific um Bill
emergency set situations could be
handled differently but um you know
whether you would still need a parental
consent to bill for that um you know
that we could talk about
okay further questions representative
Woodcock thank
you I'm still uh hung up in the the the
punitive nature of item nine uh uh to
start with and and if an educator is is
doing an action and the parent has
already had to sign off on
it because that's how we're doing the
action because they has to come back to
he I I don't understand why there is why
there is a a double issue here that if
they do that then without the second
signature that they're it's punitive
they've already agreed to it yeah
as we discussed U if this is in the IEP
and the IEP has been signed off on um
then I think that um you know we could
modify this
language okay so when yeah thank you so
when would this occur that there a
student wasn't in an IEP they had
prescribed
Services if I will for not an IEP but
still prescrib
service I I believe that there would be
uh children who qualified who did not
have an IEP um and perhaps uh someone
behind me can uh speak to
that thank you thank you Mr
chair further questions yes represent
Damon thank you I think I asked my in
the weeds question and I should have
asked the broader question
first is there a perception or
um awareness of a problem in the
utilization of Medicaid for services in
schools
I think a couple of things one we had
heard that there was in terms of getting
parental consent uh two um there are new
guidelines um that have been coming down
um from from the feds and I had
correspondence with um
DHHS and um they are looking to uh
modify rules
um based on new guidance so um you know
whether those uh new rules will include
um you know
alter alternative um uh written consent
from parents uh I'm not sure but um I
wanted to get a get out ahead of that in
terms of this
requirement
yes has there been communication with
it um it was in relation to um
specifically the uh new federal
guidelines that were being um worked on
and the new rules that would accompany
that um have they seen the bill uh I am
not
sure I I have a question that follows up
from our discussion when we had the last
Medicaid School stype
debate um if in fact the parent or the
person that's qualifying for
Medicade working with HHS checks off on
the
box that Bo I I agree to the person at
the school be it the nurse whatever
doing what you're saying right here does
the does that then take care of the
responsibility of the school having to
do this
um I think in that instance it's a it's
a onetime check off I'm looking for um
for each new uh service being pro being
provided and I I hope that uh possibly
that check off box um has been made
available since um our last discussion
where it had was not available further
questions from the committee one more
represent Woodcock thank oh thank you um
thank you Chad follow the chairman lad's
uh line thinking if the parent checked
off that I would like my child to
receive free reduced lunch that they're
qualified
for with this with this uh
account is a direct is a direct service
so no I don't believe so why because
you're not bilding Medicaid for um free
and reduced lunch for Medicare
Medicare okay
further
questions thank you very much thank you
public um no I wanted to get somebody
from the Department HHS I don't see any
here no office in the we have have
office of the Alaska and for special
ucation
Kristen okay I'd like to have Kristen uh
[Music]
Manon how about just m that's fine is it
possible um I would love to speak after
thank you chairman lad thank you members
of the committee my name is Janan
archabald I'm representing one sky
Community Services we're one of the 10
area agencies in New Hampshire that
represents individuals with
developmental disabilities and acquired
brain disorders I sit here before you in
support of this bill and the reason why
I'd like to put a face to the impact of
a piece of legislation like this you
know we all go to the doctor and we sit
there for the first 15 minutes and and
they ask you questions have you received
your colonoscopy have you received this
test have you received that test and you
sit there and you answer yes yes yes you
sit there politely for a little while
until the 10th or 11th question and then
you're finally like okay how come this
is not in the system when the doctor
you're questioning me about is literally
right next door to you and there's no
comprehensive database even for shared
um doctors on the same office now
imagine being a parent of a child with a
disability you go to the primary care
doctor who refers you to Dartmouth for a
test you go to Boston for a specialist
you go to someone on the Southshore for
therapy and then the one common
denominator amongst all of that is the
parent they're the ones who can answer
the questions when you go to the next
doctor's appointment the next therapist
has your child had this service has your
child had this test you know that might
not be recorded in the system there is
no perfect continuity of care in the
healthare system so knowing that and now
what we're faced with um in this
situation with Medicaid to schools is
we're seeing an expansion of services
which can be great a lot of offerings
here but now there's regulations coming
down with the safer communities act um
there is free care system that's being
adopted that does not require parental
consent for services delivered and build
directly to
Medicaid there also with these news
legislations you can build outside of an
IEP so Services might be provided and
you don't know what type of service that
is and that might be okay for your child
who's healthy and and and has a good
Suite of of care defined but for a child
with a disability that might not be okay
you might have a child that doesn't
react well to a certain certain therapy
or treatment and the only common
denominator at this point in time till
we get to a place where we have a great
system of continuity of care is the
parent so it's really important to a
child's health that they're tied into
all of the Care decisions they might not
choose to do anything with it but the
fact that they're armed with that
knowledge can only contribute to the
health and well-being of the child so
that's why I urge you to consider
passing this
bill so I got a question for would
School personnel
be billing out uh outside the I for
services outside the IEP of any kind or
would they all be associated with the I
AP or 504 there are new um guidelines
coming down one is I think Moyer will
talk to this with the Federal Register
that does not
require parental consent and then the
free care policy which allows schools to
Bill outside of the IEP it's called a
care policy I believe
and if do if you know who generally does
the billing within the school district
is it the individual provider like the
speech therapist or a nurse or is there
a billing office that does that well I
can't claim to be an expert on school
Medicaid billing I have been sitting in
on some of the training to try to grasp
this but it will be different for I
think every school they might have an
admin or they might ask for a third
party biller to handle their
billing so it will depend I don't think
some schools might not be doing it at
all what I understand thank you are
there questions yes represent Woodcock
thank you chairman L good afternoon just
to follow up uh on the free care piece
that you talked about it's coming down
the rules coming out if their parents
are not required to sign off on that
free care piece I think that's what you
said then um why would the St do the
state have the power to overrule that
federal
guideline I thought the federal
guidelines always took precence over
state
I don't
know is that your is that your question
oh wait that's okay you don't she be
better suited to answer that thank you
thank you chair oh thank you further
questions yes representative Cornell
Thank you thank you for taking my
questions are these new rules in effect
those have been like passed through
whoever the government where and passed
down to New Hampshire yeah so the safer
communities act um that was 2014 so yes
that one and the Federal Register is not
um
accepted not in effect right yet
followup yes so the free Care Act is
already in effect in school or I if I
didn't get the name right but school
districts are all can already provide
services without telling parents may I
defer your question to to Moira who's
much more knowledgeable on it than I am
on the specifics okay thank you further
questions thank you very much
representative
Ford thank thank you for taking my
questions I'm curious about the
authority to make that determination
that you just spoke about where is it
who who has that authority to make the
decision the Federal Register I don't
know I'm ignorant on this matter well
that would be that would be the federal
government and I and I can I printed out
a copy of it if you'd like it thank you
I'll get it afterward
sure further questions thank you very
much thank you
so uh either Moira or Kristen whichever
is best to come up
next fight it out thank you duke it out
back there no no I'm not a
fighter
okay Moira Ryan
welcome thank you chairman lad and thank
you education committee members um my
name is Mora Ryan and I'm a parent of a
son who uh has autism and I would like
to support this bill I'd like you to
considerate um and I'd like to describe
some of the situations that parents have
with Medicaid schools um so one of the
issues that has come up recently I met
with um Roberto Cardona in Washington DC
to discuss the Federal Register so the
Federal Register is a rules oriented
body so they're not really in touch with
constituents or the public or parents
and they make rules changes by publicly
posting them
and very few people know about the
Federal Register and I pointed out to
him that that might not be the best idea
but um they do rules changes that way
and they did post something where they
were going to in an effort to
streamline um processes eliminate parent
consent for services um that is
problematic to me for the very reasons
that um Miss archal had said you know I
have entire volumes of coordinated care
for my son because I have documentation
of all surgeries I have documentation of
all his speech language I have
documentation of all his OT I am the one
who is the primary care coordinator
because I coordinate with the IEP team
in the school but I also coordinate with
the medical model or the neuroses the
developmental pediatrician Etc and I'm
the only common in between those two
because the medical the medical model
and the educational model are not in
sync they were in sync when the um
education for all handicap child Act was
passed in 1975 but they've diverged in
recent years so um they're operating
under two separate systems with two
um so one of the issues that has come up
with parents that's very critical is
that if they go to their primary care
physician and they say I'd like to take
my child to do o outside speech and
language and the physician writes a
referral for two times a week
speech and language and the school has
said one time a week 15 minutes you now
have two competing opinions on what the
child needs because the insurance does
not recognize educational versus
medical so if I went to my private
insurance and I said I'd like for my son
to get these services in school they
would say to me well the school is
required to provide those so you have to
go to the school but Medicaid doesn't
necessarily do that because there's a a
a blurring of the lines there because
some kids are getting services in school
and some are not so some of the parents
have been complaining because now we
have two competing opinions where the
school person is saying this kid only
needs 15 minutes once a week and the
physician is saying two times 45 a week
so it's been creating some turbulence
because the parents are saying my my
outside services are being pulled or
limited or changed because I have two
competing opinions or because they're
getting this service and they want to
cut it down on the outside or however
it's happening for them they're finding
that they're not getting the services
that their kid needs because medical
model and education model are completely
different
entities so with those
competing you know with that competing
situation it's putting the parent in the
middle which isn't fair either I mean if
there was one thing I would like to see
happen theoretically it's that an EOB be
given to the parent for the Medicaid to
school services so they can actually
track the Serv their kid is receiving
and make sure the kid is getting you
know all the outside and all the inside
for in the school um I'd also like to
point out too that schools don't have
the obligation to follow Hippa it's not
the same as a medical um and what has
been happening in schools is yes you're
correct Representative cascaden no one
knows who has Medicaid so what the
schools have been doing is they've been
handing out the form to everyone and if
the parent signs it then they'll bill
and if the parent doesn't sign it then
they won't bill or they might try and
Bill you know without the consent but
they're not asking they're just giving
everyone the form and if it comes back
um in the emergency situation that you
had mentioned representative lakus there
are separate laws that cover emergency
situations because the the government
recognizes that we don't have time if
somebody needs a defibrillator or
something like that and the school has
the right to act and they're protected
under like a Good Samaritan style law
especially because of the emergency of
the situation um one of the programs
where uh it's outside of an IEP would be
like the renew program which is a mental
health coping program so basically um
with renew that is covered by Medicaid
so essentially when the programs were
being rolled out in schools um
administrators would say to teachers
please tell me who you would recommend
for this program who would be a good fit
for this program to learn coping
mechanisms because they are having
trouble or difficulty and they got back
tons and tons of kids and they didn't
know know which ones had Medicaid so
they just sent everybody and they saw
how it washed out but renew would be a
program which is a mental health program
which is outside of an IEP where they
could theoretically have someone be
retaining services for counseling or
um I do think it is very important for
the parent to be informed because there
was one case where a child had an
allergy and they didn't know they had
the allergy I don't know if the parent
had discussed it with them or what
happened but they were given something
they were allergic to and they had a Ser
serious allergic reaction and the kid
ended up being fine everything ended up
being fine and there was no problem but
the child wasn't aware they had the
allergy and I know my own son he tells
everybody he has no allergies he's
allergic to wool and nickel and all
kinds of stuff he's just not allergic to
any prescription
drugs
um another key component of the parental
consent if you've ever taken the
volunteer Advocate training through the
parent information center they do say to
work with the School District to sign
off with the billing but to make sure
that the services are correct and
accurate and they also advise you to um
it's a way for the parent and the the
IEP team to work together in tandem as
opposed to sort
of
negatively
um I also just wanted to mention too
that you had put in here for some
reports and I think that's a good thing
because um in my particular town the
Medicaid to school's money goes to the
town and then it gets transferred to the
school and it's not addressed in the
budget so I think it would be good for
this committee and everyone else to know
how much is being spent on Medicaid to
schools how to improve it and how to
make sure kids are getting their
services so with that I would like to
support this bill I'm happy to take any
questions questions from the
committee several years back oh
represent B Bon thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question I'm
still confused I apologize for this um
it's not easy if your child is um
recommended for services and you get the
IP and you sign off and you know exactly
what services your child is getting
correct theoretically yes okay if
anything changes with the services
they're required to reconvene and you're
require and they can't do anything
unless you sign up
again
well theoretically that would be
accurate but in practice that's not how
it
works okay um and the second part of
that would be the billing aspect it this
this whole thing seems to imply that
schools are
abusing um Medicaid
reimbursement and so my question would
be if you're signing off that your child
is getting that service um and then if
you have Medicaid and we've talked about
we the the the service providers don't
necessarily know that and you're
checking the Box um I guess I don't
understand why why that would be a
problem they just be um applying for
Medicaid reimbursement for services that
are um being
received okay so you're asking me why I
wouldn't know if Services were being
built for I'm sorry I'm not sure what
your question is I guess the question is
we I don't understand where the
disconnect is unless there seems to be
an implication that the schools aren't
following the policies I don't think
that's the implication I actually think
that they're not familiar with the
medical model and I think that that's
created some issues um I think it need I
think they need some help I mean I don't
know if uh I was here in 2019 giving
testimony before this particular
committee on
um when Medicaid to schools required
that people in schools have medical
licenses so they issued medical licenses
um and that sort of was a new component
and you know that's something where now
we're trying to function within the
educational model and the medical model
and they're really not the same thing so
I do think that there's some differences
that need to be worked out there I would
agree with
that thank
you I was going to ask you um you have a
youngster that's ages three to five not
yet in school but also receiving
Medicaid support uh via working with
HHS um and has certain services in the
home maybe whe wheelchair or other
equipment M um now the child is uh in
kindergarten in the school system do the
providers that are going to be providing
that support maybe it's uh a physical
therapist or or or such or a nurse do
they have to uh re apply for these
services or is the service that they got
through Age 3 through five directly
through
HHS we have had this discussion before
and even if the if the equipment would
even be available if it's already you
know
247 to the parent uh then is there is
the school eligible to get those
services I don't even know where that is
anymore uh so I guess I'm asking of the
first question do they have to reapply
to as a provider of that service that
physical therapist uh or or nurse again
if it's already been done in ages three
through five directly with HHS right
okay so the short answer to your
question is yes and part of the reason
is because it's coming from different
pots of money so Services three and four
come from early intervention and at five
it transitions over to the programs that
support leap kindergarten and K through
12 thank you further questions thank you
very much thank you I hope I answered
your
Kristen
good afternoon Kristen
monani uh advocate for special education
here in New
Hampshire I want to address some
questions that I think I've heard from
everyone about whether there really is
an issue of parental consent especially
for those children on
IEPs um and and by way of background one
of the things I'm concerned about with
my agency and as we um staff will
definitely be looking into ways to get
at this but there are a number of IEPs
um that really are operating with sort
of implied consent because there is a
provision that if parents do not either
explicitly consent or explicitly object
and and refuse to give consent after 14
days the IEP and the services go into
place if the Lea has made reasonable
attempts to obtain consent but that
reasonable is not defined it's a matter
of
discretion I would tell you it probably
there are probably a startling number of
implied consent IEPs in place right now
um it's something again we have a have a
information system that um may not give
us all the information we need on
special education and IEPs there are a
lot of concerns about how it operates
but one of my um big priorities for the
office would be to get to that question
of how many IEPs are out there with
implied consent as opposed to an actual
parental consent written so there are
probably a large number of instances
where you don't actually have signed
parental consent um for the services in
place this cannot happen the very first
time a child is referred right so if a
child is referred very young in order to
begin an IEP and begin to give Services
you you you don't have any provision for
implied consent but for a lot of
children these IEPs go on for years so
after the first one being put in place
yes there are in absolutely kind of
implied consent Services being
provided and I would worry in terms of
whether parents really know exactly what
those services are who those providers
are whether those providers necessarily
conflict with something else or some
other advice they're getting from a
pediatrician um if it's happening via
implied consent I could see even the
most well-meaning of school districts
saying okay we have this disability
determination or
identification we have these goals for
this
child there are times when the district
is modifying exactly how those goals are
met and and some of those modifications
are absolutely sometimes in who the
service providers are who are delivered
to that child is it an occupational
therapist is it a speech therapist is it
a um school counselor for psychological
counseling is it the special education
teacher and so there would be a whole
range of situations where I could
imagine that parents would not be aware
of services determined to be Medical in
nature and billable under Medicaid that
were being delivered in the
IEP so this is just another tool again
to make sure that that partnership
between district and parent is strong
and that there are opportunities to
discuss because it's another incentive
for school districts to say look okay we
didn't manage to get the consent we do
want to Bill these services to Medicaid
I'm all for the schools getting all of
the reimbursement money they're entitled
to for providing Services we need to
make another effort to make sure to go
back and say to the parent what is it
about you know you did you neither
refused nor
consented we're going to try again
because we have Services we would like
to
build let's figure out where the issue
is um for a lot of the parents that I
work with when they're not happy with
the IEP and hold or they don't
understand it they just don't act which
is not the most irrational thing for a
lot of us we assume if I don't sign
something one way or another then it it
can't go forward without it's just not
necessarily true so they might be acting
in a way that is rational thinking okay
I'm not going to give
consent but there is a default
background operation where services to
their going to be provided and could be
changed and and service providers could
be changed within the school so that
would be a situation that this bill
would
address thank you very much are there
questions from the
Damon could you please clarify for
me from your remarks just now I don't
understand how Occupational Therapy
Services would be provided by
some other professional who's not an
occupational therapist or similar
examples of what you just said that's
against licensing standards and they're
not trained to do
that I would think it would
be more often for example um a question
of
whether let's call it
um communication you know social
communication services for some sort of
communication order were provided
initially Maybe by um the school
counselor in a group session and then
transfer it over to a speech language
pathologist you know that speech
language pathologist might be a Medicaid
billing situation maybe the school
counselor is not with occupational
therapy sometimes you're talking about
fine motor skills and some of that might
be addressed by a special ed teacher
which then transferred over to say let's
have an OT seeing this student um is
that a good or a bad thing I mean you
know often it would be a good thing to
go to more specialized
providers all that this is looking for
as I read it is that we make sure
parents really are informed of what's
happening it it's a positive for parents
even if they're then able to as Moira
said provide that information to their
child's physician because they
understand they were asked for consent
they know who the service providers are
who are delivering services to their
child
further questions represent whitcock
thank you chairman L very quick so in
the in the the fail safe process uh
which just explaining to uh
representative uh Damon over here uh at
the worst case would the the parents
have already agreed that yes I want my
child to have this service and they
signed that off on the
IP the US say provided say for someone
in House at the council small setting
for social social skills and then the
School find someone who can do the same
thing more qualified in Medicaid it's
still the same service and they assign
it to person x what it happens to be um
so they haven't changed the service the
parent still getting the service um as
provided in the IP and minimally
wouldn't they normally see that the
annual review if there not going to be
team meeting called because they really
didn't change the service they they have
circum just find a different provider
but the at the anual wouldn't they see
that that we elated the service we
change the service or the service hasn't
changed at
all
so two things
one the parent may or may not have
agreed to the specific service right the
parent may have said said somewhere at
the outset of their child first getting
an IEP yes you know I agree either with
the school team's referral or I myself
referred my child for a specific
disability
identification and then a set of
services maybe flowed from that the
first
time it is probably more common than not
that over time the service delivery grid
and the
providers change as the child gets older
as their behavior changes there is no
requirement that a parent sign off if
they had a disagreement going with the
school team that we wouldn't really
necessarily even know anything about it
may or may not impact this kind of
service provided if they simply did
nothing
the services that the Lea was
recommending go into
place so I think it's more than that
type of situation where a parent could
really not be aware now do they become
aware at the annual
meeting yes they should if they attend
it and if the school team focuses the
parent on the service delivery grid
which is the only place that the
provider is really specified anywhere in
the IEP my experience is most IEP team
meetings don't focus on that Service
delivery grid they focus on much broader
discussions about the goals for the
child Etc so I think having an explicit
consent requirement makes everyone more
informed thank
you just a question to you is it
possible to get um some comment from doe
special ed on there on this bill well I
I absolutely think we need to uh I've
got a
question NH HHS for example if I have a
speech therapist in the school and the
IP says twice a week you will have these
meetings with a
youngster and so you're basically you're
billing based upon billable hours and
and you you you rack them up but the
second time each week it's delivered
through a par professional not the
speech pathologist and this does occur
is that service provided by the par
professional under the supervision of
the speech therapist who may not even be
at the building at the time is that
available hour to Medicaid so it's a
question I don't know the answer to but
it is a example of the type of thing I'm
talking about that you may have Services
provided by different professionals okay
we've got an answer back there on that
one
maybe okay further
discussion thank you very
much I I I apologize sorry chairman lad
could I address one other point sure um
just to say I do support potentially
looking again at at section N9 because
the educator code of conduct is
something that you know we're struggling
to use in various specific situations it
doesn't very well address as it's
written this kind of behavior so
Alternatives um are definitely something
to look at in my
opinion do you have any ideas for
us not yet I can think about them think
of them thanks please okay I'd like to
Wilson
welcome uh thank you chairman lad member
of the committee um Becky Wilson
director of governmental relations for
the New Hampshire school boards
Association uh we're not taking a
position on this bill I just wanted to
clarify a few things and maybe put some
questions out myself based on what I've
heard from other people who have
testified on this bill um I just it's
important to recognize at least for my
perception of listening to the testimony
there's two different conversations
happening one seems like a conversation
that this bill is trying to address
about billing for Medicaid to schools
the second seems to be about teams
disagreeing when they get to the service
delivery page of the IEP on Services a
child might need that are educationally
required or based versus medically
required those are in my opinion two
totally
separate
conversations Medicaid to school schols
the consent that parents sign for
Medicaid to schools only allows the
district to release personally
identifying information to a billing
company to bill for services that might
be medically necessary in
school there's no one on the IEP team
specifically typically is doing that
billing directly it goes to a whoever
the district is Contracting with to do
their Medicaid to school's billing so
that they can release the fact that that
child is getting services and the third
party can decide and look and see if the
child is eligible for Medicaid and if
the parent has provided consent for all
of those things to happen the school
district can put in for some services
and recoup a small amount of those
Services back to the school district
that money comes in at the end of the
school year it's retroactive
reimbursement it's not provided upfront
so it has nothing to do with whether or
not kids are actually getting the
services on their IEP page it's Revenue
that comes back to the school district
in a check that then towns and districts
can decide how they use their revenues
whether they put it in unexpended fund
balance or carry it over or whether it
goes to offset the tax rate that is the
Medicaid to schools piece of it in order
to bill for Medicaid to schools you need
to have a medical order a medical order
can only come from certain practitioners
an educator does not count as a person
who can put in a medical order that
comes from people like speech
pathologists OTS potentially
developmental
pediatricians other medically based PT
ex I go Audiology all of those
pieces that person that is looking at
the service page of the IEP is deciding
to quote unquote order those Services
because they are saying that those
medically Based Services are required
for the child to be able to access their
educational
environment that's why you can bill for
Medicaid to schools it has nothing to do
with the child's personal Medicaid
benefit or anything like that and the
consent that the parent is signing they
sign they can sign it every single year
it can be withdrawn at any time it's
just to release information to allow
somebody else because I think it was
said earlier District staff can't know
who's Medicaid or not Medicaid to allow
them to release the information so that
the billing can decide if they qualify
for Medicaid to schools and the school
district can recoup some money the other
situation that it seems like is being t
about a lot and I certainly don't want
to minimize it is a disagreement when a
team gets to the service delivery page
of an IEP and is trying to decide what
services are required for the child to
make progress on their IEP goals there
is sometimes a difference between
educationally
necessary services that are allow that
are required for the child to make
reasonable progress on their IEP goals
and access the gened environment versus
what a child might need medically from a
medical standpoint so there are times
where teams don't agree on that um but
that that is this in my opinion a
separate issue from Medicaid to schools
um as far as the implied consent I just
want to clarify that is one of the
standards we've talked about before that
New Hampshire has a higher level of
implied consent requirement than the
federal idea so you can't just do
something after 14 days if the parent
doesn't respond you have to have
documentation of t phone calls to the
parents other attempts made you have to
send information requesting consent or
response from a parent regular mail and
certified mail before you can ever do
something with implied consent and even
then there is a small list of things
that even if you don't get any response
from the parent you can't do that's the
New Hampshire special ed statute for
that so there while I'm not trying to
Discount any experiences I think that
probably these things are happening in
some places and that is why you put into
place the office of the specialed
advocate so that they could help to
manage some of those things but the
implied consent is not just the nobody
talks to the parents and then they get
nothing back and everything moves
forward I'm happy to try to answer any
other questions questions rep Miler
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
little point of order
here this is like the fourth
time M Wilson has been here to talk
about special education
she has a vast background in special
education but that is not her role
here her role is to represent the school
boards
Association Mr chair I'm concerned that
there's a lack of attentiveness on the
part of the Department of Education
special education department they should
be here answering these questions not
Miss
Wilson and I I would I would ask the
chair
to talk with whomever you have to over
in the department that when we're
talking about special
education that representative should be
here not Mrs Wilson because that is not
her role even though her clarifications
are
perfect I have already talked to Becky
Wilson's regarding this she's coming
here as a school board member we've
talked about that in fact just within
the last several days and and she has
that background in special ed a real
good background in special ed as well
when we introduce these bills I agree
I'd like to see somebody here from
special education doe however when we
get to a point where we are right now
there's no question this has to be put
to a subcommittee and we need to be
doing some work I'm still I still got
Mega questions myself regarding this we
went through this even prior to the prep
uh president management Administration
At
Doe and I don't know if we've ever
gotten resolution on some of the
questions and issues which exist out
there between putting an order in and
who does the billing I can remember that
you know for example speech therapist
that I talked to just the other day a
case load of 7075 kids and does the
billing now that's one heck of a
job so there's a lot of issues which we
got to look at especially when we're
talking about Medicaid schools and other
components special education so um we
will take care of this and this probably
most likely will go to a subcommittee
it's not an early bill or anything it's
not an early bill that's right we got
lots of time on this we got another
month so and we can also in room study
it you know so but okay um thank you
very much are there any more questions
Trumble
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members I'm David Trumble from the town
ofwar I have some concerns about the
bill but I just want to back up and go
over the special aspects of it I think
that the code of conduct punishment
model is totally inappropriate for this
sort of situation you've heard that the
billing system is extremely complex and
despite extensive questioning it's not
clear you've heard that sometimes
parents won't show up to certain
meetings and so that leaves people in
limbo there's obviously the question of
can you find service providers in
certain locations instead of a
punishment model I would suggest a
training model that you would say if a
school is out of compliance with this
that you will find people who know how
this system works and make it available
to them there's no reason to punish
teachers and it was indicated that
teachers really have nothing to do with
the billing
the second thing is that what's step
away from the special ed cases it's not
clear that this bill only applies to
special ed cases I looked up the the
code and there are other things besides
special ed that applies to the um the
ICD codes for instance social
determinance of Health which which
according to the AMA are responsible for
50 to 70% of an individual's health so
these are social risk factors associated
with poor health such as food insecurity
housing instability and there are icd1
codes for homelessness inadequate
housing and food insecurity we know that
60% of school teachers regularly give
food to their children under this bill
that would be I I think if if the
language of the bill says to render or
provide services if this teacher gives
food on a Friday afternoon and Tucks
food into their child's backpack that's
rendering a Serv Serv for an icd10 code
I don't think that's the intent of the
bill but I think it should be looked
into more so that it's clear that this
if this is just a special ed Bill and
only special ed then it should be stated
as such in the bill so there's no
confusion whatsoever the other question
I have is well what about transgender
students because trans also is an icd10
code so it's very vague here what is
rendering or providing a service if a
child is a student is using their
pronoun rendering a service is having
books available for them if a child is
on puberty blockers and the parent comes
and tells the teacher that this is
happening and the teacher tries to make
some accommodations is that somehow
providing a service what is a referral
what if a parent confronts a teacher
about their trans child and the teacher
refers them to a family counselor is
that a referral and and even in that
case how would the teacher even know if
the student was a Medicaid student or
not and as it was clearly pointed out
teachers aren't supposed to know that so
there's just I would like it to be very
specifically stated that this bill is
only dealing with special education if
teachers provide food or make a referral
to a housing for a family who's become
homeless they're not going to be
punished under the code of conduct if
and that has nothing to do with
transgender students it shouldn't have
anything if it's a special ed bill it
should be clearly stated as such that's
all I just think it's a little bit
unclear and as you said if you go to
study committee perhaps you can
straighten out those things thank you
thank you Mr Trumble are there any
questions not seeing thank you very much
you welcome with that I don't think we
have any further pin cards up here on
this bill so we're going to close
1616 and that closes down the hearings
for
tomorrow repent
for thank you Mr chair one of the w
witnesses that we spoke to after the
hearing asked me to make an announcement
it's about a television show that they
recommended that we all watch if I
may sure go ahead it's a a show she
described
as Stampede I think it's a a show on uh
one of the specializ shows uh uh that
you can get on the regular TV situation
it has to do she said to be sure to
watch it from the beginning it's called
stamped not Stampede I misspoke stamped
St a m p apostrophe D I guess or D you
know but that's the name of the show and
they recommended it all uh to you thank
you for everyone they also made the
observation that it's
very I forgotten the exact word she used
but UNC comfortable for them to appear
before a committee that has no persons
of color on it
okay thank you very much thank you
that's what they said thank
you
did did you say out in the hallway until
we that was nice of her wasn't it yeah
yelling at
me I did enjoy that um what's the say
9:30 9:30 good doing at 9 yeah yeah I I
I would suggest
well yeah not okay yeah can we do it at
like quarter 9ine is that too
thinking yeah so well we're going to
tomorrow yeah I know it it's getting
really
old email we haven't tried Thursday
tried
de where is Ford
coming know but I feel like it's getting
worse it is getting much worse yeah I'm
it's